What's up ladies and gentlemen?
One more time.
Here we go.
This episode of the Joe Rogan
experience podcast is brought to you by
squarespace.
Squarespace is one of our newest
sponsors and a great website resource for
anyone who's thinking about starting a
website and really has no idea how to
begin.
A squarespace's is truly the
ultimate all in one platform.
You can create your own website yourself.
You don't need to learn html.
It's a setup,
very easy to use,
very intuitive design,
excellent images,
and you can.
You can set up a bunch of different
variety is a websites and you can even try
it without paying for it.
If you go
sign up,
go to squarespace.com,
forward slash Joe.
No credit card needed.
Just try it out and start
building your website.
If you decide to purchase,
then use the offer code Joe Three.
That's three because this is march
that we're doing this podcast.
Use the code Joe and the number
three and you get 10 percent off.
Your first purchase on new accounts
includes monthly and annual plans.
That's squarespace.com.
Forward Slash Joe.
It's a really sweet setup,
including online commerce,
which is really a very convenient,
easy to use.
You can set up your own online store.
It's really fast,
really easy to do 24 slash seven support,
responsive design.
Your site's going to
look great on any device,
iphone,
android,
whatever,
and you get a free domain name
if you sign up for a year.
So you go to squarespace.com,
forward slash Joe,
and if you decide to sign up and use it,
use the code Joe Three and
save yourself some Lula.
Ladies and gentlemen,
come on.
We're saving you 10 percent so
you can design your luscious.
Delicious.
You're lovely suicide
sitting on the train track.
Yeah.
What are they doing it?
We don't live forever.
We're crazy.
This is where we make love.
I want blah,
blah.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible].
I'm ting is a mobile cell phone
company that uses a sprint backbone.
And uh,
I don't know how they did this.
I don't know if it was like
other people have had this idea.
Are there people who have
done things like this before,
but what they decided to do was,
I guess they rent,
they rent time on the sprint backbone
and they sell it back to you.
And the way they do it is they have their
company setup in a way that it makes
it.
Like if you were gonna like,
I wish my company did this,
I wish my company had no contracts.
I wish my company would
refund money if I didn't use,
uh,
the,
the minutes credit on unused service if
you use less than you thought you would,
tear drops you down and credits you
the difference on your next bill.
So I've never heard of
a company doing that.
It's beautiful.
I love hearing that Shit.
Unlimited devices on one plan.
You can have as many devices on you want
on one plan and you can share pooled
minutes messages and megabytes.
And each device has a plan on a plant,
costs a flat fee of $6 per month.
It's like it's beautiful company.
Um,
they also have the best android phones.
You can buy really cool ones
like the Samsung Galaxy note too,
which is that giant fucking delicious one
kid's screen envy every time I see it.
So pretty bad ass looking foam.
They have the galaxy s three.
I think they're getting the s four.
That's how is that out yet?
The s four?
Not quite out yet.
It's not out.
It's on the way out.
They keep pumping these out,
man.
It's.
It's really interesting because they
really have lit a fire under apple's ass
because for the longest time there was
no benefit to having any device other
than an iphone.
I had that touch screen blackberry because
I was trying to stick with verizon.
Oh my God.
What a piece of shit.
That was.
What a wretched clunky
clicky piece of shit.
You're in Austin now.
You weren't in denial because
you still might hate it.
I just liked verizon.
I used,
back then I used phones more.
I used my phone to make calls.
I was very,
very little texting and never online,
so for me it was just important
that I could use it to,
you know,
to call people.
But then it was just too,
it was too hard.
He would try to get
your email or something.
It was a fucking joke to try to
write an email and that click,
click,
click.
Every time you touch it,
click,
click.
So Tonka Shits and you know,
you just see would look at the iphone,
you'd feel sad.
But that's not the case anymore.
These new phones are actually,
they have benefits over the iphone.
The biggest one being a screen
screens are fucking huge.
The galaxy s three,
the one that I have,
it's beautiful.
And if you look at a website and it's
such a different experience and looking on
a website on my phone and the note takes
it to the next level of known as like
five inches.
It's fucking gigantic like me
snipped in on your lads.
If you go to Rogan.ting.com,
you save yourself 25 bucks
on either a device or um,
or,
or credit for service as well.
So the 25 bucks is
applicable to either one.
It's [inaudible] dot ting.com.
And again,
really great phones,
really great ethical company.
It just,
it all works,
bitches.
It's beautiful and delicious.
So go team for business.
I'm going with that is
probably something good.
They probably have better,
bigger plans or something.
Yeah.
We're also brought to you
by [inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t if you haven't seen
the chimp kettlebells are out there,
uh,
the first of this new thing that
we're doing called primal bells.
And what we've done is a hire artists to,
um,
create,
uh,
these,
these images to create
sculptures of angry chimpanzees.
One of them we've got,
I don't want to give away,
I already gave away the gorilla,
the gorilla.
So dope.
I couldn't keep it together.
But there's,
there's a bunch of really cool ones
we have coming out and it's all,
they're all designed by someone
who does special effects models.
They do like,
you know,
monsters,
monster movie type Shit.
So we hired him to make a Kettlebell.
We also three d scanned it to
make sure that it's totally,
completely balanced.
The problem with these sort of joke
workout pieces of equipment is,
and then they look great,
but they're not as
effective as the real thing.
These are as effective as
any kettlebell you get.
You have to watch which way your hand it.
Um,
handle it so that the chimp
face as a slam in your arm.
But even if it did,
it's okay.
I've,
I've used them both ways.
It's not that big of a deal,
especially if you're a
manly man like myself,
but the point is that it's
their excellently bounced.
We had unbalanced absolutely perfectly
with really thick handles too.
So it's really difficult to use,
which is what you want.
You want something to
really work your grip in.
If you've never had any kettlebell
exercise in your life before,
I urge you to find a trainer and
have someone show you in person.
If you can afford that,
if you can't,
there's a lot of online videos.
But,
um,
if you go to like youtube,
there's many,
many,
many online instructional
that you can get for free.
But you want to really be
diligent about your form.
You really want to be diligent
about your actual fitness level.
Don't push yourself too quick and hurt
yourself and you don't lift too much
weight too easily,
just in the beginnings or too
quickly rather than beginning.
Try Light,
lighter weights.
Try just,
you know,
you're just trying to
build slowly every day.
Just write it down.
Make yourself do it.
If you really want to get in shape
and if you really want to work hard,
don't go all at once.
That's crazy because
when you go all at once,
you break things.
You fuck up your muscles,
you pull things,
your hurt,
your knees.
Don't do that.
You gotta you gotta train if you're going
to train hard and you should have been
training hard for years already,
and so the.
The idea behind a functional fitness
like kettlebells or steel maces or steel
clubs,
these clubs,
bells,
all these different things that we
sell is the idea of using things using
workout equipment that provides you
with functional real world strength.
So if you're in the mountains
and a mountain lion jumps
and you managed to get a
hold of his neck,
how confident are you in your endurance?
How long can you fight
this motherfucker off?
Is it a difference between life or death?
In some situations,
most likely the mountain lions can fuck
you up unless you have some sort of a
knife or he's a pussy.
Could get lucky and find some pussy ass
mountain lion that maybe got fucked up
by a bear a couple of weeks ago and it
still doesn't have a stage legs back
under them.
PTSD,
PTSD.
Some woman got attacked by
a wolf recently in Alberta.
Fucking crazy shit.
She had these bite marks on her neck,
but there was a bunch of people around.
So apparently the wolf flutter go big.
Two hundred pound Timberwolf just took
this lady down and bit her neck and a
bunch of people around there and people
were freaking out because there were so
many people and people were freaking out.
The wolf just bailed,
but he got so bold and so scary that he
jumped on this chick and the chick just
got in her car and drove to the hospital.
It's a crazy story,
man.
Wolf let go of her neck.
I mean,
she's got these cuts,
like there's images of it.
You could find it online.
There's images of her neck.
She got off relatively lucky.
She's lucky it was on wolf a pack.
Well,
I think if it was a lone wolf,
it's also positive possible.
That's why it was so fucking hungry
that got kicked out of the pack.
Like if it's a big old male,
you know,
it might be that it's on its way out
and some new mail took over and now he's
fucked.
He's out there by himself.
That's how they die.
That's a.
that's a.
that's an exile on the wolf world.
That's a fucking terrible,
terrible thing.
Those,
I mean,
they're essentially saying,
we've got no room for any anymore,
dude.
You gotta you gotTa
fucking kick the bricks.
As poor wolf's got to go out
and try to get some elk himself.
It's hard for one both to kill an elk.
You got to get a gang of them and you've
got no fucking box them in and take
them out by the legs and look
for the little ones and you know,
but those wolves on their own man,
this bit,
this chick's neck.
Well maybe if the bitch Nigga little
Jujitsu and had some kettlebell training,
she could fight off that Pussy Wolf
that will obviously it was a pussy.
You know,
if they're like bites in
the neck and then he's like,
fuck.
He got that close.
You're not going to try to eat her.
You know,
are we talking to dating now?
Are still with the wolves?
Okay Dude,
you can't say them on the podcast podcast.
We're talking about defending yourself.
Get Wolves
now by a wolf.
What if they were the best at it?
What if I get super dangerous?
You know,
every now and then someone
got their pussy bit,
but for the most part,
like orgasms by Wolf,
eating your pussy.
He's like the greatest thing ever.
It's put their snout in there.
It's a really muscular tongues and
that they're not scared to get dirty.
You know,
I don't know if this is appropriate,
but when I heard a lot of stories about
women who are menstruating camping and
the blood attracted grizzly bears and you
gotta be really careful camping with a
woman who's been destroyed.
God and what are the bare
decides that you're a pussy for?
That's what they do and they
find the one with that missing.
Oh my God,
that's so scary.
It's not a good image.
That's such a scary animal.
The scariest thing about them,
we've talked about this
in the podcast before,
but is that they don't kill you.
They just started eating.
Some animals will kill you first.
Well,
that's a black bear.
No.
Even Grizzlies,
they don't kill you.
They will kill you eventually,
but they start eating you.
They don't.
They don't have that instinct like a
panther does to bite your neck and stop
your life and then consume you and they
don't do that because for two reasons.
One thing is probably because
they're so fucking big and powerful.
It's like they don't really
have any enemies like,
besides man,
right?
So they don't feel like once they got.
Yeah,
they just take the time and eat,
you know,
and they're so strong that like
a deer can't really hurt them,
you know,
for bear gets a hold of a deer.
That deer.
Good,
good luck swatting at kicking and,
you know,
but uh,
a deer kicking can fuck up.
A mountain lion could
kick him in the face,
break his jaw,
and then was the mountain lion.
Dude,
he's fucked.
He can't eat.
He's going to starve to death.
So the mountain lion,
it's imperative for to take that deer
out as quickly and cleanly as possible.
They go white for the neck,
they roll onto the body.
I mean,
it's really like a Jujitsu move.
They choke the life out of you.
They always go for the neck.
They don't try to take you out
like in the middle of your back,
you know,
they,
they go right where it's
going to be the quickest,
most effective way.
Bears on do that.
They just started eating you.
They just hold you down and start eating.
Yeah.
Grizzly bears,
uh,
I mean,
I,
I was in Alaska two years.
I know a lot more than I
should about bears probably,
but I think that the reason a lot of
people survive grizzly bear attacks,
but not black bear attacks.
Two reasons.
One,
black bears climb trees.
Grizzlies don't.
So you can't climb a tree.
And the other thing is
grizzlies will often,
and this ties into what you're saying,
grizzlies will often think they killed
you and then they'll kick some dirt over
you so you can play dead with a grizzly.
They'll kick some dirt over you.
And often they'll come back later because
they like the meat putrefying French
cheese.
They like,
it's stinky and gooey here.
They actually compost,
you know,
it really.
Do they cover you with leaves and dirt?
It's sort of a must be Dha.
Is it to hide or to
accentuate the process?
I wonder.
Yeah.
Good cooking.
You are cooking.
You with brought dirty containing animals.
We know everybody is like that.
People love bears and I,
I think they're majestic and I'm certainly
not saying we should eradicate them
for the face of the planet,
but the only reason why we love them is
because they're not in our lives on a
daily basis.
If we had grizzly bears in our streets,
you would have fucking wheel problems,
man.
Like monster movie problems where it's
going to eat your children right in front
of.
Have you seen grizzly man?
Have I seen his filling?
Huh?
Recommended to everyone.
Yeah.
I guess we were in the
middle of a commercial.
Sorry.
No,
don't,
don't apologize.
That's how we like to do it.
I'm just a lot of good shit there folks.
If you go to a audit.com o n n I t,
there's all sorts of different supplements
as well as cool fitness equipment,
but if you're looking for that kind
of strength and functional fitness
equipment,
we have you covered battle ropes,
kettlebells,
club bells,
all that good shit.
Gummy bears,
but actually do have a company in Paris.
We have government.
We sell certain foods that we
find finding me really healthy,
like a hemp protein powder and coconut
oil and stuff along those lines.
But we also have these,
um,
Omega three gummy worms.
Wow.
Yeah.
My kids.
Well,
one of my kids likes it and the
other kid is not into it at all.
We have these fish oil,
their official jellies.
One of my kids loves him.
She asked for all the time.
He fucking hates it.
The other one thinks it tastes like shit.
This is terrible.
Look at her face,
but the little one just gobbles it up.
It's really good for him.
You know,
it's a way of getting kids,
uh,
essential.
Uh,
central fatty acids.
A killer honey as well.
We got done Himalayan salt
and all sorts of good shit.
O n n I t a,
the code named Rogan.
He will save 10 percent off
any and all supplements.
I like the overview.
Just shows a bunch of boats in the water.
The what?
Review.
This is the overview for the.
It's a bunch of boats.
You guys sell boats.
It's like,
Hey,
we can get it from the city water.
What does it say?
Oh,
fish oil distributors.
Is that what it says?
No oil jellies for kids overview.
Here's a boat.
Yeah.
It doesn't say anything,
but we got our fish from a boat.
See boats float in the water.
That is really stupid.
Why would they show boats?
Did you know that?
Fish live in water and
people don't live in water.
Look like shitty old birds.
Doesn't look like good water.
They come from like Norway.
They don't have.
They don't really need to
have any better boats in that.
Just Shazam blue water,
you know?
Nice beach.
Well those are the boats that go and
get our fish that we need to make our
essential jellies.
How dare you.
Brian,
do you ever watch that
fucking deadliest catch show?
They don't have like the coolest boats.
Those guys aren't yachts.
We snuck this girl and using these boats.
Yeah.
What's that girl doing?
Certified young fellow kids.
Full of Shit.
They paid it all the hands like that.
She's like,
totally.
They give a real real chocolate
if she can just fuck it.
We have a hershey's bar
right behind the camera.
Honey,
I need to just make two
fists like a fighter.
Chuck Liddell make leg.
Chuck Liddell.
Yeah,
they photoshop the.
The handcuffs offer thumbs up.
You can see like right here,
there's like a handcuffed that
hasn't been photoshop off.
If you look at the left arm,
it looks clearly.
Duck taped doesn't look real at all.
What is the hair?
Okay.
Don't be a fucking doctor.
Laser.
Oh look,
she's got one strand of hair over white
shoulder and the rest of her hair's
behind.
It's not a mystery at all.
You fuck.
No.
You're a conspiracy.
Tinfoil hat.
Picture Guy.
You're looking for issues.
This ain't even a real kid.
That's a boy's head.
They gave him fucking ponytails.
I got news for you.
Boys and girls look pretty much the
same when therefore no one knows.
Really fucking branched out
and run away from the pack yet,
but I'm on a Dotcom O,
n n I t go name,
Rogan.
Alright.
Dr Chris Ryan is here.
We're going to figure some shit out folks.
We're gonna.
Explore some ideas.
We're going to expose
some cultural problems.
We have hit the music.
No,
please.
Okay,
the Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast all day,
international man of mystery World Travel,
man,
author,
Xtrordinair.
You're a,
you have a broad range of experiences
that you can draw upon Mr Chris Ryan,
and to appreciate you very
much coming back here again.
Thanks man.
It's an honor.
Oh please.
It's an honor to have you
back to your book is amazing.
If you haven't read it.
I've been reading it
over the past few months.
Um,
along with the new Steve
Rinella book meat eater.
I can throw you back and
forth with this book.
It's a great book,
man.
There's so much interesting shit in it.
It's a,
it's such a fascinating sort of exposure
about sexuality and evolution and how
we sort of evolved and how we've,
you know,
got to this point where it's kind of
gotten away from us and there's all this.
I think Duncan trussell said it best.
He said that you exercise
shame from people.
You know what that term,
until I told you I'm working on
a new website using squarespace,
which is not bullshit.
I'm not saying that,
but my,
you know,
we've got Chris Ryan and
then under it says a author,
public speaker or something.
I love that phrase.
Yeah,
you're.
That book is.
Yeah.
For a lot of people it makes you go,
oh,
okay.
That's why these fucked
up thoughts or come,
I'm not fucked up.
Everybody's system's fucked up.
Oh,
we're living in this crazy time of shame,
chime of a
oddly defined identities and roles
that we're supposed to take on.
That seemed very unnatural.
You know,
and it's,
it's weird times.
We live in weird time sexually.
I think we do,
you know,
the Chinese thing,
may you live in interesting times,
which is a curse,
you know,
but I think we do.
We do live in very interesting times.
There's a quote we use in
the book from the playwright,
Arthur Miller,
who was married to
Marilyn Monroe for awhile.
He said,
uh,
an era can be considered
over when it's basic.
Illusions have been exhausted.
I'd love that quote.
It's basic illusions who have been
experienced and I think we live in a time
where pretty much all our basic
illusions are exhausted politics.
Nobody thinks they're the shit that's
going on in Washington is anything other
than,
you know,
back the yield trading for whatever,
I'm banking,
nobody believes banking is for
the good of the country anymore.
It's like people have realized
that everyone's on the take.
The institutions are not respected and
that includes marriage to a large extent.
And so there's this struggle going on
over marriage and monogamy and gay rights,
you know,
in terms of a same sex marriage.
So I think we're in this war.
I mean there's so many things,
diet,
you know,
you're on the forefront of a lot
of this sort of recalibrating,
you know,
what works,
what's right,
what actually has benefits,
you know,
as opposed to the bullshit that
we're being fed all the time.
So.
And I think a lot of that's
due to the Internet probably,
that you can,
you know,
if your message is strong enough,
it doesn't matter who you are,
who's backing you,
you can reach people.
So I think,
yeah,
I think we're in really interesting times.
It's an effect on our culture
of that the workforce,
the workplace brings and it's,
excuse me
everyday during the,
at the workplace,
you know,
some of my black,
but uh,
no,
I'm good.
Thanks man.
That's a beard.
That's a beer at least 10 minutes.
Black Butte,
but tea butte.
It's a delicious Porter Ale.
I would like to have one
of those and get moved.
It's um,
yeah,
I,
I drank some of that for the
first time when I was a man.
I want to say Chicago where
I think it was in Chicago.
Yeah.
It was like the greatest beer I've
ever had in my life from bend,
Oregon.
Yeah.
What's the name of the company?
Uh,
the shoots,
shoots brewery.
Hey,
how dare you.
They should be a sponsor.
How about we just pump them up for free?
For free.
All right,
well that's good.
It's good beer.
And that's from a guy who
doesn't like porter much.
I was saying earlier,
it's normally kind of
heavy and sweet for me,
but this is nice.
Yeah,
no,
that's delicious.
What are we talking about
before we got off workplace?
You're talking about workplace.
Thanks for the.
I really feel like because
of the fact that you have to,
when you're in an office all day,
especially,
um,
with men and women working together,
there's this sort of professionalism
that you have to project.
There's this sort of fake way
of communicating where you,
you've completely eradicated anything
sexual from the menu of conversation and
even discussing it in the periphery,
dancing around it with a joke can
easily get you fired or you know,
about this dongle gate thing.
Are you aware of this memo?
I've heard reference to it,
but I haven't looked into it.
It's a fascinating story that has taken
place over the last few days in the tech
world.
There was a woman,
a self professed feminist blogger.
Woman's.
Sorry folks.
I've got a little phlegm,
Jimmy,
me,
um,
some tissues I gotta blow my nose.
I'm.
This woman was at a conference and
some men behind her made a joke about
dongles.
It was someone said Dongguan says this
essentially is that dongle part of
something.
But it was what they're essentially doing
was I'm doing like a high tech version
of Beavis and butthead.
He said,
dongle biggest dawn was,
you know,
so these guys,
I don't know what the joke was,
but.
So she takes a photo of these guys and
then puts that photo online and says,
Hey,
these guys are violating the code of
conduct for the seminar and these guys are
on a,
you know,
in your conference there,
they're making jokes about
dongles are not cool.
Okay.
So these guys get fired
and one guy gets fired.
He's got three kids and
this woman writes his blog,
sort of justifying like
the environment that,
you know,
that sort of makes cool.
And that's the reason why she decided to
come out was because there was a little
girl on stage or a little
girl in the room or whatever.
And she was thinking,
what was this little girl?
If I don't stand up and stop this,
what is she going to be exposed to it?
Which is of grandiose when you're talking
about Dongles,
Jesus fucking Christ.
But what's truly fascinating
about this whole thing is a,
first of all,
the response by the Internet
because the man was fired.
Um,
but don't put those guys online.
Dude,
why are we doing that?
I mean there's no need to keep.
Yeah,
I know.
I mean,
I just don't think they,
they didn't ask to be online.
Those guys never asked to be on those.
Those photos were taken by this woman
and it turned into this big thing.
She has like an online media
thing that she does already.
So she is like a big presence,
a lot of twitter followers.
And she just took a photo of these guys
and just put them out in the world for
no reason.
I mean they didn't ask
for it and she says,
here's the guys that tell the Dongle joke.
So one guy gets fired.
She writes this crazy blog
and anonymous jumps in there,
like,
what?
Fuck you.
Oh really?
They were like,
this is absolutely fucking posture
is the way this woman's behaving is
repulsive.
And it just went off.
And so they threatened the company and
they said they were going to go after
their clients and they were gonna,
you know,
denial of service attacks and
whatever they were going to do.
Like,
I don't know if you need even directly
threatened it or indirectly threaten it,
but they're like,
you,
you got to,
this is just the beginning.
You've got to get rid of this check.
And they fired her immediately.
Oh,
I thought you meant the
company that fired the guy.
Did they different kinds of.
I don't know if they brought the guy back,
but you really,
the guy should get a job at a company
that's not a bunch of fucking pussies
because that's the most
ridiculous shit ever.
And one man,
isn't it?
Like it's nothing.
You know,
I,
I haven't had a job since the eighties,
so I'm not the guy that really,
you know,
but I can't imagine pissing
into a cup to have a job.
I don't understand that drug test,
drug test for insanity
and complete insanity.
The fuck does it matter if I smoked a
joint two weeks ago and I come into work
today,
what the hell are we talking about?
It's insane.
Complete total insanity
and it's just this sort of
designed to get people moving in this
direction of blind obedience and that's
what your employer would like for you.
But by the way,
I think that's another one of these
basic illusions that's exhausted.
We got ran Paul coming
out for legalizing drugs.
Yes.
I just saw the headline.
You know,
so I,
I think maybe we've turned a corner.
It's gotten so crazy that,
you know,
anonymous is standing up.
That's great.
I think the Internet represents the real
mind of the people today and I think
when,
when a big movement like this
sweeps across the Internet,
and this is a very minor one,
let's go with a major one.
Let's go with wikileaks.
The overwhelming support of Wiki leaks
by people online as opposed to how it's
represented in the mainstream
media is a big difference,
isn't it?
People Online,
it's like people 35 and under.
Mostly.
I don't think so anymore.
No,
I don't think that's applicable anymore.
I think pretty much everybody's online.
I think there's been over the last decade
there's been this assimilation towards
older and older folks and then the people
who are 30 or now 40 and that's just,
it's,
you know,
I think the ideas are too powerful
and the method of distribution is too
powerful and now we're dealing with
this ancient paradigm that doesn't,
it doesn't really work with the amount
of information that we have today.
It's like this old car that we're trying
to keep fixing and putting new tires on
your fucking model t it's
a piece of shit it worse.
Cuba as Cuba's got least cool cars,
they really take care of.
Well,
it's an amazing model of like recycling
and true recycling and the unnecessary
aspects of constantly getting
new and improved things.
A friend of mine wrote a book called the
Chase Chevrolet and Castro's oldsmobile
or something like that.
I mean,
his name is Richard Schweid.
It's,
he's written this guy so interesting.
He's published seven books,
one on Chili peppers,
one on cockroaches,
one on,
uh,
you know,
life after death.
One on Cuban cars,
he just like w eels,
he's got a book on,
he just like gets a hair up his ass and
decide something's interesting and he'll
just run it down and write a book about
it and then move onto something else.
That's amazing.
Uh,
what,
what I was saying earlier before I got,
before I got sidetracked about the
workplace is that the suppression of your
true humanity in the workplace,
your,
your ability to be free and
to be yourself and to be,
to joke around and have fun,
especially when there's
intersects politics when there's,
you know,
there's a cross of men and
women working together.
There's this sort of like fakeness that
goes on all day and then there's this
other level of fakeness that goes on
when you're out in the night lifetime
you're trying to get laid like,
so there's that fakeness as well.
And there's just such a small
percentage of time that humans,
men and women throughout the day interact
with each other on a truly honest
level,
you know?
So like it takes fucking decades
to understand each other.
It takes decades as a man under just
try to wrap your head around the idea of
wanting babies growing inside of
you and wanting dicks and you know,
and being attracted to men.
Just wrapping your head around that.
It's a very strange concept because
we bullshit each other all day at work
before because we bullshit each
other when we'd go out on dates.
So social events,
we pretend to be someone you know,
more sophisticated or
interesting than we truly are.
Um,
I think that the amount,
the amount of time it takes before you
start understanding how people really are
as opposed to these bizarre
patterns that we keep following,
you know,
it seems,
and you didn't even mention media.
All the bullshit media pumps
into us about each other.
Men and women have a
unique relationship with,
uh,
with television.
And then had been
on a couple shows that
went on a long time.
I was on news radio for five years and
then it was on fear factor for six years
or so when people say,
oh,
there's a conspiracy and the government's
trying to dumb us down through
television.
That's not what's happening.
What's happening is
that's what you're buying,
that's what they're selling because that's
what you're buying and that's one of
the reasons why it's gotten darker
and weirder over the past few years.
Just because you're on the Internet
now and the walking dead could not have
fucking existed a decade ago.
No way you could have that on television.
I saw a dude get his leg
hacked off with a hatchet,
you know?
I mean,
you see shit.
I couldn't believe what was the sheer
violence and insanity of the walking dead
is impossible without the
internet and video games.
Video Games,
absolutely these uncensored environments,
but that information's there now,
so they have to adjust and change things,
but the reason why fear factor
existed or or CSI exists,
it's not that the government
is like trying to convince you.
If you make a mistake,
we'll catch you.
We can take your
fingerprints from the air,
you know,
like,
no,
no.
It's just,
that's what you want.
You want crime shows.
You're buying crime shows.
If you buy crime shows because you're
scared because you look what's happening
in the world will hold
what if the bad guy,
so you're living your life in these weird
paranoid ideas through this artificial
medium,
but no one's trying to brainwash you.
You think they are,
but it's really more a matter of this
is what people actually bought and is it
because that's what
they've been sold forever.
Yeah,
that too.
Definitely that too,
but there's a lot of dummies out there.
There's a lot of domains that just want
to sit in front of the TV and watch
someone get go to what's going
to happen on law and order.
I'm going to guess the bad
guy's going to lose because I'm.
No,
I agree.
I agree with you.
Although I do think that there is.
It's not brainwashing,
but I think who was at Marshall
Mcluhan said the medium is the message,
right?
Yeah.
So there's certain things
that you sell that are,
that are easier to sell through TV.
So you sell those.
Right,
and they're the structure.
I mean,
I'm reading this book now,
civilized to death.
It's called him,
so I'm really like deep into the shit,
but it's like there are
institutions are organic beings,
companies are organic beings,
so they,
you're right,
they sell the,
they provide what sells because they're,
they need to eat,
they need to feed,
you know,
and grow.
But I do think that there are structural,
how can I say it,
like structural biases that,
that divert or,
or,
uh,
you know,
sort of focus the media in different ways
and I think Internet is great because
it's so dispersed.
Whereas TV is very,
I'm selling to you.
I don't hear a thing you say,
except through Nielsen ratings
or some shit like that.
It's like they're getting smoke signals.
They're not getting a conversation.
Whereas the Internet,
it's like,
wow,
you've got clicks.
You eyes,
you can
measure everything.
That's interesting.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
The idea of,
you know,
this is what we're going to offer you.
It doesn't exist on the internet and
the choices are so vast that and the
freedom that anybody
like you have a podcast,
right?
Generally speaking,
as you can tell,
it's my style.
What's your preference for this podcast?
Um,
that,
the,
you know,
any,
anything along these lines that the
youtube videos that people have the young
Turks or have these video.
My last episode was with the Young
Turks that couldn't have existed.
We talked about.
Yeah,
are they like you,
it couldn't have existed without,
without the Youtube possibility,
the Internet possibility without,
with,
without that sort of a platform.
And I think that sort of overwhelming
the old paradigm and it's slowly starting
to a road.
Um,
but I,
I also feel that the workplace,
like people,
people having to bullshit all
day is counterproductive to it.
And it becomes a major part
of your awake time program.
Yeah.
It's so American.
I have to say in Spain,
you know,
I can't speak for Spain in general,
but I've been there 20 years.
So I,
I,
you know,
I've,
I'm pretty well familiar with the culture,
but it's one of the things I love about
Spain is that politically correct sort
of,
you know,
men are the enemies of women
and adolescent joking can
get you fired from your
job.
That isn't happening now.
Women could have a
legitimate point by saying,
yeah,
because women's status in Spain isn't
as high as it is in there aren't legal
protections and that,
you know,
women get harassed in
the street or whatever,
and that's all true.
So I don't mean to say Spain
is across the board better,
but one thing I noticed in
Spain and I love about Spain,
is that women,
women don't assume you're a
rapist because you smile at them,
you know,
they,
they don't assume you've
got bad intentions.
In fact,
they assume you probably
have good intentions and you
just find them attractive
and they smile back and everybody
keeps walking and there's no.
It's like a win win.
You know,
there's no assumption of
victimization going on.
I think in America
there's this assumption,
you know,
that,
that you know why there's a little girl
on stage and these guys are making a
dumb ass jokes somehow that's
connected and I got to expose this.
I don't,
I don't see that in Spain you
don't see that sort of shit.
Well,
the,
the fury that people had was this.
They weren't joking with her.
They weren't,
they were joking amongst themselves and
literally the most innocent language
possible for describing a dick or alluding
to a dick and that was enough for her
to go.
I've had enough like the.
There's a craziness to that and someone
made a video called toxic women and
stupid men and it's on youtube and deep,
very in a very intelligent way.
Details why people that think like
this or a real issue and men who allow
them to get away with it without
saying this is preposterous.
Their real issue too,
because there's a lot of
white nights out there.
There's a lot of really dumb weak dudes
that want to pretend that there with the
girls,
they think like,
you know,
you're right.
These men are assholes and they'll make
videos about it and what they're looking
for is like feminine Brownie points.
They want feminist to
look at them and say,
yeah,
you're one of us,
and it's not necessarily that they
don't actually think that way.
A lot of people are like,
you're wrong,
but I,
I believe you do think like that,
but I'm telling you that the motivation
for anybody thinking like that is false.
You have a crazy,
ridiculous way of looking at things.
It's unbalanced.
If you had no sex whatsoever,
not male nor female,
and you look at that as two human beings
and one human being was fired because
another human being made a joke about
something that was being referenced
onstage in a playful manner.
Should that person be
taking sex out of it?
Should that person be fired?
Right?
And if you say yes,
you're a cunt,
that's,
that's the reality of the situation.
You're a toxic person.
That's a shitty way of looking at things.
And by the way,
I should stress that this woman did not
want these guys to be fired and she did
not think that was her intent.
She wanted them shut up.
Whatever is maybe she's self righteous.
Maybe she likes to go off on tangents.
I don't think she should be fired.
I don't think he should be fired.
I think it has nothing to do with
whatever the fuck they do during the day,
but I think it's fascinating when people
are forced to be behaving in a certain
way.
Like you're,
you're,
you're locked into this sort of nonsense
environment where you can't even talk
about dongles.
Yeah.
You know,
there's an article on salon.com,
I think last week I linked to it and
it started this big firestorm on my
facebook page where a woman wrote about
an experience she'd had the first time
she'd had sex.
I think she was 15 or something and she
was with a guy a couple of years older.
And,
um,
she just said she had a few drinks.
You read it.
Yeah.
And so she was saying that wasn't rape.
I made a bad decision.
I had sex that I later
regretted it wasn't rape.
And apparently like,
oh,
there's a huge firestorm around this.
Yes,
there is.
Because there's the
feminist movement right now.
Then one of the ideas that they're
pushing is the idea that is in place,
I believe in Sweden.
Whereas the,
you know,
where the,
the idea being that regret,
um,
means that you can withdraw your consent,
which is where a Julian Assan is
being accused of rape the woman he is
supposedly rape,
went out with them again the next night
and had sex with them right before
what he was being accused of.
I don't want to speak out of school,
but I'm pretty sure it
was called surprise sex.
It was the idea they were sleeping and
they had sex again without a condom.
Yeah,
exactly.
And she didn't want this or she
was upset at this or whatever,
you know,
obviously they were looking to
get at him for something else,
but that's about as obvious.
You can get that one.
I mean that is just fucking,
it's just so happens that it's the same
guy that had no beef with them about
leaking all the information.
That's cool because there's
no law against that.
Right?
Is that what's going on?
But the other shit you can,
you can lock them up in a fucking.
Didn't Brenda this morning?
Yeah.
Fuck man.
They torture Bradley Manning truly
torchy's a hero that was in solitary
confinement for some insane hundreds and
hundreds of days with no contact with
another person,
which they say literally
can make you crazy.
Yeah,
sure.
And they wouldn't,
they would take his clothes off because
they thought that he was a security
risk.
So he's cold and naked lights
all night lights constantly,
and you know,
for what,
because he did what really his patriotic
duty led him to believe that he should
do.
You should release information that he
believes is contrary to the nature of the
contrary to the idea of what most
people view of the military as,
as only good guys over
there killing bad guys.
And contrary to the law.
Yes.
You know,
international and American law.
Yeah.
He,
what he did was what the New
York Times is supposed to do.
You know what Daniel Ellsberg.
Yeah.
There's a,
you know,
so I think the,
I,
the view of that,
that's getting back to the
Internet thing on the Internet,
that's pretty.
I mean,
most of the people that I communicate
with that's pretty much unanimous.
I mean,
pretty much everybody is like,
well,
you know,
at the very least this exposes a real
issue that should be dealt with in the
military,
but you don't hear that from
mainstream media for mainstream media.
They have eliminated that
guy from the discussion.
You never hear him being talked about.
See,
that's what I was saying earlier,
like the structure of the
of the institution dictates
what information can go
through there.
So because of the corporate interest,
because Ge owns NBC or whatever their
and also makes the fucking missiles and
the helicopters and the rest of it,
they're not going to be able to take
that perspective because they're not
independent.
That's bullshit,
right?
Well,
as some people like the
young Turks come along,
they really become archaic.
They don't make any sense anymore
because the young Turks will tell you,
you know,
they're going to tell
you what they believe.
One hundred percent with
that guy believes what?
They might not be.
Right.
They may be mean.
He was off about Breitbart,
about what the whole Andrew Wiener thing
he made fun of Breitbart for releasing
that Jank.
Yeah.
Saying he's an idiot for doing
it and it turned out to be true,
but you know that,
that he,
that's him.
That's him.
You know what I mean?
He's talking straight to the camera,
so maybe it doesn't have the
correct information at the time,
but what he's telling you,
it's not being pushed by producers.
It's not being pushed by a network not
being pushed by a corporate entity behind
the network.
Right?
You can't say that about the news that
we've come to accept as the mainstream
news,
whether it's CNN or Fox.
There's no individual voice is no
individual point of view and you know,
especially being.
Occasionally you'll have
people give editorials,
but those editorials or just Jesus Christ,
Allah,
cartoonish.
They're cartoonish and nonsensical.
Especially like Fox News is going to be
about the Democrats and Obama is fucking
up and we turn to socialism.
It's going to be so hot.
It's so obvious.
You don't even have to say it.
Just show me what color
flag you hold them up.
You've got a red flag or a blue flag.
I your message.
Just show me a red,
a flash of red.
And that idea is basically just as good
as whatever the fuck comes out of your
mouth.
Yeah.
You're going to have to have me back a
third time because we're never going to.
Oh,
we will though,
man.
We will.
But I really wanted to
have you one after this.
This thing,
this dongle gate broke out because
I think one of the things
that your book really,
really highlights is the weirdness in
which women are not supposed to except
their sexuality or accept the fact that
they get horny or broadcasted in any way
or even you know,
it acknowledge it and that if there's
a sexual joke going on where a man,
even if he doesn't even
involve that woman,
make some sort of a sexual joke,
that somehow that woman is
a victim because she doesn't
want to have anything to
do with sex.
Right?
She doesn't want to have
anything to do with their,
either their advances or jokes about it.
Korean image.
You know,
the Victorian era.
You only had sex with your
wife in order to have babies.
You had sex to have sex with.
Court assigns with prostitutes,
with,
you know,
the housemaid with whatever you didn't
fuck your wife for fun or for pleasure.
Was that across the board.
Kevin agreed.
Upperclass Victorian British
society across the board,
you know,
not on,
in France and other European societies.
There is a different vibe,
but that's the society Darwin came out.
Right.
And as we tried to explain in the book,
that's the mentality that informs our
understanding and the scientific view of
human sexual revolution because
Darwin was an uptight guy.
He was great.
He was a genius.
He's a cool guy,
but he was super repressed.
Sexual.
He never had sex ever.
Right.
Isn't the only with his wife whom,
who was his first cousin
from the Wedgewood family,
which are the Wedgewood,
China.
Fortunately they still,
they're still making China and in England.
Um,
and she was 30,
I think he was 29.
And his brother married with Newton.
Newton was a sexual right.
Yeah.
Didn't have during the.
Excuse me.
During the Victorian era,
didn't they cover up like legs of pianos?
Right.
And tables and chairs.
Oh yeah.
Because it would excite people.
It's so amazing.
It's like,
it's like
the Burka,
now you know why?
Oh,
it's crazier than the Burka,
but you know,
what's cool about the
burqa and I'm doing this,
I'm pitching this TV show,
which seems like it's going
to get picked up by the way.
And,
and the,
um,
one of the episodes is about,
is based on the story I heard from a
woman who worked at Victoria's secret in
London and she told me that most of the
lingerie they sold was to very wealthy
Saudi and Kuwaiti women who came in and
we'd just buy out the store because they
were sexy lingerie under their Berkus.
Yeah.
But it's under that stupid 10.
They do.
I mean,
it's got to be compensating for the fact
that they're forced to wear that stupid
outfit.
I don't think there's anything
good about that outfit.
I mean,
the only thing good about it
is if you're the man like,
man,
nobody gives a look at this
says mine's going into the tent.
It's just the what,
you know,
what's offensive.
Not the religious connection to it,
but the suppression,
the idea that a woman has to wear that.
Right.
It's the most depressing thing ever.
You're covering everything
about your identity,
right?
Especially it fucks up a girl if she's
in a shit relationship and she's looking
for another dude.
She's looking for a little escape plan.
You know that guy has no.
What the fuck is getting into dress
getting abused and nobody can see her.
Her bruise marks.
That's another way that.
Yeah.
That's another point.
Anyway,
I jumped off.
What were we talking about?
That
shit before.
Oh Man,
I'm not even stone.
Yeah.
Oh,
we were just talking about the suppression
of sexuality that women don't feel
like a
Koreans in Darwin and all that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
when we originally pitched this book,
it was called what Darwin didn't know
about sex and the idea was to write a
biography of Darwin sex life and then tie
that into our modern misconceptions of
sexuality because he went and
he had lots of opportunity,
right?
He went on the Beagle all
down around South America,
across the South Pacific.
They stopped in Tahiti,
which is sexual paradise,
especially in the 19th century.
It was,
it was sexual paradise.
That's why the mutiny on the
bounty happened because the,
the bounty.
You've seen the movie,
right?
The Marlin Brando.
I never saw that movie.
Well,
it's this,
uh,
so the,
the,
the bounty I guess was captain,
I don't remember what his name was,
captain something flusher
or something like that.
But anyway,
it was a British,
a whaling ship I think,
or mapping ship maybe.
But anyway,
it stopped in Tahiti to spend about
a month or two months there to like,
you know,
get fresh water and fix the
ship and do all this stuff.
Meanwhile the dudes went down and they
were on the island and there's a very
relaxed sexual situation into hedy
and in many parts of the world.
And so these repressed British sailors
who hadn't seen a woman and God knows how
long.
Suddenly there are all these beautiful
women around who were happy to have sex
with them just for fun.
And uh,
so these guys are getting
laid left and right.
And then the,
the bad ass captain says,
all right,
everybody back on the ship,
we're going back to see.
They get about four hours out to sea.
And there's a mutiny
because the dudes are like,
fuck this,
we're going to go back to England.
We're going back to the hedy men.
So that's what they did.
So this is this famous case because
there was like lots of Nice Pussy.
You mean Nice women on your say pussy,
you're,
you're objectifying women.
You're breaking them
down to one body part.
I know what year,
Hey,
that's even worse.
I,
your intentions are pure.
But for our women friends out there,
that would be the white knight take on it.
Well done.
Calling them,
calling them by their sexual organs.
It's really not cool,
man.
Well last night I was at a party
and a woman said something,
said some guy was a real dick.
And I and everyone laughed.
I said,
that's funny.
If someone was a country
I'd would be sort of nasty.
Right?
So we got into this whole conversation
about how come one body parts offensive
and the other isn't well is
like if she called him a coc,
that guy's a cock.
That still,
depending on how the
guy felt about the girl,
you know,
if he thought she thought he was the shit,
that would be a problem,
that'd be devastating.
I was a couple of weeks ago I gave a
Ted talk or talking about this corporate
environment and um,
you know,
ted is Ted's wonderful.
I think you had a guest.
You're the guy who was there.
Anyone.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Graham Hancock,
who also has had issues.
Graham Hancock's had a very
interesting situation and shelter.
Rupert sheldrake is good
friends with Stanley Kripner.
You're going to be interviewing Saturday.
Yeah.
He probably knows hancock as well,
I don't know.
But all those old hippie stick together.
Yeah.
Intellectual,
freaky guys.
Um,
but uh,
anyway,
so I've got this presentation
and when I did the rehearsal,
one of the slides and the presentation
that I've used all over and know colleges
all over and stuff,
it's got.
I'm talking about testicular ratio and
how that explained certain things about
our ancestors.
So I've got in one corner,
there's a gorilla lying on his back
and the sun and there's like nothing.
He's got no balls at all.
They're like the size of kidney beans.
They're inside his abdomen,
so you don't see anything.
On the other corner,
there's a Banaba who's got
balls the size of chicken eggs,
and in the middle there's a
picture of this buddy of mine in a,
in a speedo sitting on a hammock and
he's got pretty big balls and so the law,
it says like gorilla,
but Nobo and over my
friend it says Italian.
Right.
That always gets a huge
laugh when I do that.
I did this at Ted and they were like,
okay,
you know,
after the rehearsal they're like,
oh,
that was really good.
That's great.
Except that one.
And they.
They thought Italians would be offended.
Oh my God.
I'm always saying,
you tell that Italian,
he's got big balls.
That's a compliment.
Little do they know they have big
balls because the Italian women are so
permissible.
Read the book.
Yes.
Devastating.
Devastating to the Italian mentality.
I can't believe it.
Maybe that's the part that's insulting.
The size of your package is directly
proportionate to how slutty girls around
you are.
I shouldn't say slutty and that was a
another fascinating aspect of your book
that I learned the origins
of the word promiscuous,
that everybody was sort of
assumes that promiscuity,
when United State Girls Promiscuous,
that she just sleeps with
strangers and runs around.
She's got loose morals.
That's not the root of the word.
The root of the word is mixed,
meaning she has sex with
more than one person.
She has relations with
Generally speaking,
probably knew those people her entire
life because the real origins of these
sort of orgiastic tribal
societies of that,
there's only 50 of them.
They were living together in the woods
and they knew each other from the time
they were born and they had sex
with each other and they had sexual
relationships with more than one person.
And our ideas of,
you know,
monogamy,
it's great if it works for you.
If it works for you in 2013 and the
corporate world and the legal world is
great,
but if you look at 50 people
living alone in the woods,
staying bonded together,
the best way for everybody to truly
love each other as everybody fucks
everybody.
I mean you,
you really are like monkey people.
I mean your,
your monkey people with more advanced
genetics and more advanced tools and shit,
but you're essentially living
not much different than you know,
than an animal with tools.
You know,
I mean,
that's how people at
the dawn of time lived.
Those people,
it would benefit them
to be sexually engaged.
Each.
It would benefit them to be polyamorous.
It would benefit them
to have love spread out,
you know,
deep,
intense love with bunch of tribal members.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
no,
no question.
In fact,
when I was,
you know,
I,
I'd done all this research on tribal
people and they're really interesting
rituals that are seem designed to make
sure that people don't break down into
nuclear families,
right?
They,
they're designed to make sure even though
you and this woman really like being
together and,
and you know your hammocks are next to
each other and you spend most of your
time together.
That's great.
And we're not saying that there was
no pair bonding right in prehistory,
but all these cultures seem to have these
rituals to make sure that you and your
woman both have sex with other people,
right?
So like they're tattooing ceremonies where
everybody has sex and it's prohibited
to have sex with your normal partner.
Whoa.
Or there what Wacky fucking cultures.
If it's in the Amazon,
there are lots of the
men in the South Pacific.
That's what happens when
you don't have the Internet.
Start getting crazy
sets one assholes idea email.
It's one guy,
Richard,
I'm going to fuck your wife.
You're going to fuck my wife.
I want to fuck your wife.
Dude,
let me make it a law.
A law firm.
You have to make it a law
that's fucking silly that,
I mean they're social engineering
is no better than ours or theirs.
They'll do what you want to do.
This other societies,
the
Kulina,
uh,
Paula Don pollock was the anthropologist
who lived with them for 20 years.
He talks about this ritual,
I don't know how to pronounce it,
but uh,
the,
the translates to the order to get meat
and the women will wake up in the and
they,
they get together and they say,
okay,
let's do this thing today.
So they all start singing and they'll
go around the village singing the song
that translates to you guys are lazy.
We don't get enough meat,
when are you going to give us some meat?
We want me,
right?
So they're singing this and it's.
And I asked him,
does meet to have a double meaning it?
And he said,
yeah,
definitely.
It's like same as go hunting
but also give us some Dick,
right?
So while they're singing the song,
they go around and the women will beat
on the post that's holding the guys
hammock.
And that means if you go hunting
today and you bring back some meat,
I'll sleep with you tonight.
So it's like a motivation to get
out of your hammock and go hunting,
but you can't hit the post
of your normal partner.
It has to be someone else.
Right?
So then the men can,
if they don't,
like,
if you don't want to have sex
with a woman who hit your post,
you can say,
oh my stomach today,
you know,
whenever I'm not feeling
well you don't have to do it.
But.
So the guys who get up,
they'll like get up and be all,
oh,
you know,
grumbly and pissed off and then
they'll go leave the village together.
But this area they hunt mostly monkeys.
And so they hunt independently,
right?
Because the monkeys are spread out.
So.
But before they split up to go hunting,
they'll agree to meet at this certain
point before they go into the village.
So the uh,
or the camp or whatever.
So they'll go out,
some of them will get a monkey,
someone they meet back at this place
and they cut up the monkey so that
everybody has a piece of meat
going back into the village.
So everybody gets laid,
right?
So it's like pretty clearly,
this is all about mixing it up and it's
not just for fun because there's nothing
else to do.
It's also to,
to,
um,
to mitigate the risk of conflict,
right?
Because if you get possessive about
other people and their sexuality,
you're going to have lots of conflicts
and conflict among this small shows.
Social Group,
as you say,
it's 50 to 150 maximum,
right?
Because of Dunbar's number,
which we can get into if you want.
But we can be pretty sure that the groups
were never more than 150 individuals.
So the worst thing that can happen is
you get schisms within that group because
you're all depending on each other.
You know,
some people are better
hunters than others.
Some people are better at cooking
or making bows and arrows,
sheds and all this kind of stuff.
Is that the origin of Dunbar's number?
Is that why we only have room in
our head for supposedly 150 close
relationships?
Yeah.
Dunbar's is a biologist that
either Cambridge or Oxford,
I don't remember which,
but he was looking at um,
uh,
the,
the brain size of different primates
and he found that he could predict the
social,
the group of the social,
uh,
size of the social group of any
primate by looking at its neocortex.
And so when he looked at humans
and made that calculation,
he said,
okay,
it should be about 150.
And then they looked at the
anthropological record and they found,
yeah,
interesting.
When these social groups
grew to more than 150,
they split.
They tend to split into other groups,
not
acrimoniously just because
this.
So we've sort of developed a,
a need for a certain amount of space.
It's,
yeah,
it's like that's as many
people as we can keep track of.
And because we didn't encounter large
groups that was adequate for the time and
it takes a long fucking time for the
human genetics to adjust to their new
environment,
which is very odd.
But it made sense for a million years,
for a million years.
It totally made sense until the last
few hundred and then things just have
gotten so strange that the human genetics
are essentially the same as those
people that are living in the Amazon.
Yeah,
I mean,
there have been some changes.
There's a great book called the 10,000
year explosion that talks about the,
the genetic changes that have
happened since agriculture.
What are they like the
most significant ones?
Well,
eye color,
skin color,
hair color,
you know,
there,
there were no blue eyed
people 10,000 years ago.
They know that DNA.
Wow.
They've got like 10,000 year old people.
DNA.
Like that old dude that fell on the,
uh,
the ice man selling the a glacier.
That's,
if you haven't heard of that story,
believably amazing story
because it's such a rare fine.
This guy died and he fell in a crevasse
and the glacier went over him and didn't
wipe them out.
And that's really rare.
Most things,
glaciers were like a
mile high plus sometimes.
And as they moved across Europe
and across North America,
across everywhere on the world.
And at one point in time there's glaciers,
right?
Well,
equatorial region,
70 equator,
right.
The,
the,
what they would do is just completely
erase everything that's in front of them.
Yeah.
Because houses,
trees just crush everything rivers
at all.
So anything that died back then that
got crushed by this slow moving glacier.
We have nothing.
We have no evidence of it.
That's,
you know,
I've got a book idea that relates to this.
That's a really good point.
I hadn't thought about
the glaciers are racing,
stuff like that.
What I thought the book idea is,
you don't remember how Rumsfeld going
into a rack said they're the known knowns
and the known unknowns and the unknown.
Uh,
remember that whole thing.
He's don't remember that he gave his
press conference and somebody was talking
about predicting what was gonna happen
and he said they're the known knowns,
the known unknowns and
the unknown unknowns.
So the things you know,
you know,
things you know,
you don't know and the things you
don't know that you don't know what.
It's kind of an interesting of
shitty idea to go to war with that.
Exactly.
So what I was thinking is write
a book about the known unknowns,
the things we know we don't know,
but that we ignore.
Like for example,
in anther anthropology,
archeology,
you're talking about the glaciers
wiping out whatever it was there,
which is absolutely the teenagers.
Why about houses?
They would wipe the valley,
you
know,
gone.
Yeah.
So,
um,
it's pretty complete,
you know,
but the other was like,
one,
you know,
people left Africa.
Uh,
the current understanding is about 70,000
years ago and spread out around our
40,000 years ago.
Seventy thousand years
ago is the Toba eruption,
which almost wiped out our species.
There were genetic tests show that
there were about 3000 couples,
a reproducing couples that have
the genetic line has continued.
So there was this huge bottleneck
because the lake Toba is now Lake Toba in
Sumatra was this eruption that triggered
an immediate ice age and like the feet
of ash all over Asia and just killed
everything and triggered winter it was
really nasty.
But anyway,
the,
about 40,000 years ago,
our ancestors left Africa,
the out of Africa,
you know,
event and they spread
out around the world,
but they mostly follow the coastline,
right?
Which you would,
right,
because that's where like foods washing
up and there's shellfish in there and
you've got good sight lines.
So those bears and leopards and shit,
you'll see them come in,
right?
You can run into the water
to get away from him.
And you know,
the,
the sort of,
um,
the water that's not too deep,
you don't have sharks,
but it's deep enough to
keep the leopards away.
Right,
right.
Um,
so that's,
and it's easier to walk on the beach,
right?
So that's,
that was the root of the huge
exodus that went around the world,
but sea levels were about
300 feet lower than.
Whoa.
So the stuff they're finding,
you know,
the whatever the stone tools
or the remains that there,
they're finding from a 30,
40,000 years ago,
those weren't typical at all.
The typical people were down on the beach.
So those must have been hunting parties
or people who were exiled or whatever.
But they weren't at all typical.
That's interesting.
So I bet we're missing a lot of the
fossils and the little bits of evidence of
those people that lived on the beach,
which was the majority of the people.
And that's the stuff
that's a representative.
So it's pretty weird to build your image
of a society based on evidence that you
know,
is extraordinary,
you know,
but that's what we do
because that's all we got.
I can remember really
clearly being in college,
uh,
thinking about human history,
um,
I,
I don't remember what the
subject of the class was,
but then I remember being in class and
just getting an idea just for the first
time,
but in,
in very roughly of how little we know
about just what the fuck actually happened
when you really start reading
books about events and,
you know,
I'm reading about like I was reading
about custer's last stand and um,
you know,
the,
the account of the Indians account
and the survivors account and know,
trying to piece it all together.
I'm like,
well,
how crazy is it?
Is really difficult to piece
this together in my head.
You know,
but today I can watch September happened
or I can watch a plane hit the tower.
I can look the way we have recorded
things today is so vastly more intricate
that when I look at what I know of,
you know,
jfk getting shot,
what I know of seeing troops in Vietnam,
like this history that is,
you know,
that I think of when you look at how
little we know about 10,000 years ago,
30,000 years ago,
40,000 years ago,
and then the idea that the only way you
find things as if people died in like a
volcano or a mud slide because you got
to get a fossil or fell into a peat bog.
It's like how many people
fall into peat bogs?
How much,
you know,
not enough fucking crazy.
What if all the smart people just rotted
in the ground and then go into this
fucking bug?
It was a whole race of super intelligent
people that never went into peat bogs
ever.
You know,
the earth.
The first neanderthal
remains that were found,
um,
were like hunched over
and sort of deformed.
And so for a long time,
the image of a neanderthal
was this deformed crazy.
Turns out that was like a
really diseased individual,
right?
It wasn't a typical neanderthal.
Listen,
it isn't a typical data
finding them very damaged,
especially their spines.
And like there's a lot of
times they're really fun.
A lot of.
Yeah,
a lot of hunting accidents and also
apparently a lot of wear and tear on the
teeth and stuff.
Yeah,
yeah.
I would imagine.
Yeah.
And,
or tunnels.
Yeah.
Anyway.
It's um,
it's just,
it's really strange.
I,
I've often said that human beings today,
it's almost like waking up in the
middle of history as a person,
as an individual.
I've felt that way sometimes watching
a documentary or reading a book about
something or trying to imagine what it's
been like several hundred years ago.
It's like,
all this has happened already
and it's all real clear.
You can sort of piece it together and go.
And then we got here and
it's like we woke up,
we woke up and go,
we're,
where are we?
Where are we?
Where on earth.
Okay.
How do we get to earth?
Well,
this is what we've calculated and
they lay out a piece of paper,
okay,
earth is near the sun and the sun
is surrounded by this other planets.
Does another earth Muslim maybe?
Probably most likely.
Actually it's infinite.
So every possibility will exist.
Infinite numbers of times.
That's the real infinite.
So we're like,
okay,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And then someone goes,
hey man,
I figured some shit out.
It's called quantum
theory and you're like,
what the fuck are you saying?
And then dude,
there's gorillas.
You'd go to the jungle,
they found fucking gorilla.
They're big,
they're black,
they're sorta human.
Like get the fuck Outta here.
I'm telling you,
there's monsters out there.
Like all that was,
that's the 18 hundreds.
I mean they didn't,
they didn't.
The Western world didn't know
the existence of gorillas
until the 18 hundreds.
So it's kind of fascinating
when you really think of
like where we are right now
and how,
how much we know about how we got here
and you and you didn't know
Bonobos till the 19 seventies,
you know,
are really start studying.
I mean,
they thought they were just
a sub species of chimp.
They called them pigmeat.
Chimps.
Turns out they're so completely
different from chimps that they.
They've forced us to completely reevaluate
the primate origins of human beings.
Yeah.
It really threw a monkey wrench in the
whole explanation of why we're so warring
and horrible violent.
Want to do that?
I swear to God,
no pun intended,
but the functional note
Banabos are like Super Sexual.
They,
they solve everything
with sex and the sex.
They don't have as the mother
doesn't have sex with a son.
Man.
You did your homework.
Now I've just been fascinated by monkeys.
My whole life's apes.
Champs.
Sorry.
Mostly Champs.
But other apes as well.
Uh,
but yeah,
apes.
I know monkey sounds cooler though,
among gender.
Transgender monkeys have tails.
That's your right.
Monkey balls is such a good phrase,
you know.
I mean,
I use it all the time even though
I'm always talking about eight balls,
but the eight ball just doesn't ring.
Yeah.
That's why I.
my one of my comedy specialist was talking
monkeys in space because talking apes
in space just didn't.
Yeah.
It's missing something in Spanish.
There's no word for Ayp,
actually real,
which makes things complicated in
translating our book to Spanish.
So is it just primates?
Various premium names.
Simeon.
That's it.
That's another good one.
Yeah.
The monkey,
the monkey wrench.
That was thrown in though
to get back to the bonobos.
Bonobos are not violent.
They don't.
They don't kill other Benobos
then they just fuck all the time.
Friends do all the great
Dutch primatologist who's
responsible for bringing
Benobos to public light to a large extent.
He said chimps use violence to get sex,
but no booze.
Use Sex to avoid violence.
And bonobos are very
interesting and as you know,
people understand the chimps and Bonobos
are our two closest primate relatives
by far and in fact there
we're more closely related
to them then they are to any
other primates.
So if you go to a zoo
and you're looking at it,
you know chimp cage,
that champ is more shares,
more DNA with you than he does with a
gorilla or an orangutan or anything,
right?
Yeah.
So in fact,
jared diamond wrote a book called the
third chimpanzee where he argued that
humans,
chimps and Bonobos are basically
three subspecies of chimpanzee,
were so closely related,
were more closely related to them than
an Indian elephant is to an African
elephant.
Right.
We're like super close in terms of DNA.
So they're.
But they're very close to each other.
So I think of it as like
if I've got twin brothers,
they're closest to each other,
but after each other comes me and
I'm equally related to each of them.
So the champ,
as you say,
it's kind of bad ass kind
of very male dominated,
very hierarchical,
kind of conflictive can be really nasty,
you know,
rip people's faces off in Connecticut.
But the Bonobo in 50 years of
observation in the wild and in captivity,
no one has ever seen Urbanova kill or
rape and other Banaba that'll have to
rape.
They just fuck they don't do it.
If you want to not get raped,
just give it up every way you look.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah,
we can never live like them.
I'd say.
I do not agree with that.
I'm just saying it in,
in the animal world,
that's what they do,
right?
I mean,
that's where they,
they never killed a rapist.
Very interesting.
When you're talking about animals,
like a lot of people say that orangutan
sex is rape because the male chases the
female through the tree tops and she's
screaming and apparently trying to get
away.
Right?
That's a dolphin three isn't.
There is a indication of Dolphin rave
with dolphins are also involved in mass
genocide.
Infanticide rather killed baby dolphins.
They kill them to get
the females to breed.
That's typical of,
of uh,
a lot of mammals learning ends.
Do that,
do this,
do that.
When there's an Alpha male gorillas
when there's an Alpha male and he takes
over,
often he'll kill the.
Or if there's a coalition,
they'll kill the babies to get them back.
The women back into estrous.
It's brutal.
In fact,
that's one of the theories,
Sarah Hrdy,
who's written widely,
she's very well known
primatologist anthropologist.
One of,
um,
the theories is that the reason that
females are promiscuous in some primate
species is to confuse paternity so that
males won't be tempted to kill babies in
order to get women back into
a female back into estrous.
And that's the current
thinking on dolphins as well.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Dolphin females are known to
be like the slots of the ocean.
They have sex,
sex as many guys as possible.
So the guy comes over,
he goes,
yeah.
So while they have that
bond with that person,
what do they establish as the main
reason why the chimpanzees and Bonobos
though?
So genetically similar,
so different behaviorally.
That's a really good question.
The,
there's no perfect theory.
The best known theory is that,
um,
the chimps and Bonobos,
we're the same species and
there was a change in the Congo,
the,
the root of the Congo River,
I think about 5 million years
ago and that's been verified.
And uh,
so one population got isolated on the
south side of the Congo and the other on
the north and the ones on
the south became Benobos.
The ones on the north became chimps.
And the idea,
and this is um,
Richard Wrangham at
Harvard proposed this idea,
is that the chimps on the north,
we're competing with gorillas for
some of the same food sources,
whereas there are no
gorilla south of Congo,
so the Banabos weren't competing
for those food sources,
so they didn't have to get gangster.
Right?
But the problem with that theory is that
it basically dismisses the assumptions
of Darwinian evolution based on Malthus,
which is that any population
will quickly grow to the point where the,
where the food resources are saturated.
And so you get competition between
individuals for whatever's there,
right?
He seems to be saying the population of
Banabos never grew to the point where
they were competing for food,
therefore they never
had to get competitive.
If that's true,
that's a radical statement.
It happens to be a statement I agree with.
I've made the same statement
about early humans.
I'm saying,
hey,
early humans were like,
you know,
these pythons that are
introduced into the everglades.
They're like,
whoa,
there's nothing else here
competing for this niche.
Well,
it kind of makes sense if you really
think about it in terms of how we look at
socialism,
because what are the number one
complaint from manly man about socialism?
It's going to make a soft,
which are fucking pussies have
just socialists out there yet.
That's the idea.
The idea is to soften everybody the fuck
up to reduce the need of competition
and to a lot of people,
especially people that have adopted
sort of a advantageous positions,
they look at that as like,
Hey,
fucking plus age,
you gotta earn it.
You know,
socialism is the idea.
It sort of makes sense if you
look at the buffalo community,
right?
Yeah.
They didn't have competition so everybody
just chilled out and they developed a
style of being that's more chilled out.
Right,
right.
It is a great story.
I'll tell you a guy you should interview.
I think I mentioned him last time.
Robert Sapolsky.
I tried.
I'm trying.
He's in the middle of teaching.
Oh,
okay.
So you've been in touch
for sure.
I learned everything about toxo plasma,
which this podcast is for him to death
and they got so tired of talking about
today.
Do you,
do you tell the same story?
Sometimes?
Yeah.
Sometimes I get tweets from people like,
dude,
great,
love your podcast,
but you told that story three times.
Like how do you keep track?
It's really hard when you're having a
guest if the guest is not aware of the
information because I don't want
to like write it down and say,
okay,
when the podcast is over
I got to tell you about
the changes the way you behave.
Um,
so sometimes if it's a new gas
and they don't know about it,
I kinda,
I'm sort of forced to.
I tried to give them the
cliff notes version of it.
I know about it.
So pasky had an amazing video,
um,
where he detailed and it even went
into that when he was a med student.
They would find a cadaver's like guys
who died on motorcycles and there was a
disproportionate amount of them that
tested positive for toxoplasma takers,
risk takers,
that the parasite literally
gets you to take risks.
And that there's a direct correlation
between toxo plasma infestation and
successful soccer teams.
Wow.
So they all have cats in the locker room.
No.
Well,
this is two thoughts behind that.
One is it could be purely,
that doesn't cause it's not,
it's not in the fact that's just a
correlation correlation in that it's just,
you're dealing with people that
live in impoverished areas.
People in impoverished areas
have higher incidents of cats,
hired incidences of feral cats is more
likely toxoplasma that they're also more
desperate and maybe more invested in
soccer and more aggressive in their
approach because it means so much
to them because it's a way out,
you know,
much like impoverished
people in America sometimes,
you know,
they,
they make some of the greatest athletic
stories or someone who came from nothing
and was so never wanted to go back
to that again and had so much drive.
So I don't know if he can act absolutely
connected two of them together.
But it is a fascinating theory.
You
talking about taking risks.
Uh,
as I've gotten older,
I've developed this concept
I call the bucket list.
So the,
you know,
the bucket list is stuff you
want to do before you die.
Right.
But like I turned 51 a couple of weeks
ago and I'm at the stage now where I've
got a fuck it list were things I used
to think I wanted to do before I die.
And now I'm like,
yeah,
fuck it.
You know,
like one g jumping.
No,
no,
no.
Fuck it.
That's definitely on a fucking noisy.
Yeah.
I'll show you a video.
A Guy Bungee jumps in his,
his cord was not long enough.
Slice slams off the ground in agony.
And then with the body he has court is
too long ago with his broken body slams
off the ground again and it does like
several times he's got like a helmet
camera in the screens and
he makes are horrific.
He didn't die.
He lived because it slowed
him down a little bit,
but I mean it just broke him and then
spring up in the air and then smashed back
down again.
I mean,
I don't know if he lived after the video,
but he's alive during
the video and it'll cure.
You have any ideas of bungee jumping?
I hope it wasn't Antosz point.
Oh,
you probably covered it.
He's probably got a fucking 10
minutes of his act about it.
Really?
Yeah.
He's,
he's covered everything.
Fucked up.
That's ever been released
on the young Turks.
He's in the same building.
Oh,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I,
I did a show with Doug Stanhope recently
who went and we did this thing where it
was a guy who was a lifelong
virgin trying to give them advice,
but a bucket list.
That's a good one for the bucket list.
Punchkick just bungee jumping.
Skydiving.
I could be convinced to skydive
if it was with some friends.
Fuck No.
Tell him.
Tell him the story.
My Dad was this girl that my dad worked
with skydived all the time and every
know she always tried to get him to do it.
So finally he was going to do it and then
like a week before you're supposed to
do it.
Uh,
she jumped and heard a chute,
didn't open,
and then the reserve chute start tangling
with the other shooter and then she
died.
So it's like my dad was supposed to do
it like the following week or something.
We can add that to the fuck.
Fuck it.
That's all she did it.
She was a pro.
It was just,
you know,
a bad shoot.
I did a hair a.
I always forget Paris lighting.
What's the difference?
Parasailing is behind a boat,
right?
Yeah.
No I do paragliding.
Jumping off a mountain.
Oh my God.
I did this in indy.
I took,
it was really dumb but cheap.
It was cheap.
It was.
So it's your life.
It was in Goa and there's this German
guy on the beach where I was staying in
this Hippie beach and go,
uh,
called Aaron Bull.
Whereas Gola go as a,
the just below Mumbai in India.
It's on the west coast of India and it's
like this legendary hippy place like
Philips since the sixties.
Hippies have been going there to chill
out on these amazing beaches and small
cash and you know,
do yoga and shit.
So I was there for 10 years
ago or something and you know,
we were there for two weeks,
two months on this beach.
Like I didn't wear shoes for two months,
it was just so great and so I was
looking for stuff to do and there's this
German guy who have a who was teaching,
you know,
you do these classes and
it was like for 10 jumps,
100 bucks or something.
So I signed up and you do the first day
theory and you learn like learn some
weird shit.
Like there are these cloud formations,
it'll suck you up into them and when
you're like in the cloud you don't know
what's up and what's down.
And so there are all
these things you like.
It's like instrument control.
You have to like,
even if you think you're falling upward,
you have to pull the shit and fall.
And it's like,
oh,
that's weird and horrible stuff.
What is the cloud formation?
That's sucks you up.
What's that all about?
I don't remember.
I just remember like,
you know,
I will not go near those clouds.
The wizard of Oz type of situation.
It was some,
some particular cloud formation that,
that has a really strong updraft.
It's like,
um,
you know,
what's it called on the beach
where you get sucked out to ocean,
the untitled,
like you have to go against it.
Not against it die.
I'm 90 degree angle.
Not trying to get out of it.
Like you don't swim against the undertow,
you swim across the undertone,
right?
Same thing in this case
because you get sucked up.
Your body freezes and then
they'll find you like far,
far away,
frozen,
solid.
Like it's either the iceman.
Yeah,
we didn't finish the story.
The reason why this guy didn't
get smushed is because uh,
he like fell into the bottom of this
crevasse and got covered and turned into a
essentially like frozen dinner
and a mummy frozen mummy.
So if people like,
what the fuck?
He never finished that story.
Do you know Brad Pitt has a tattoo of it.
See on his arm.
Doesn't really know he's really into etsy.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
Why?
I guess he's just super into it.
So,
you know,
maybe we'd have to ask Brad Pitt.
You've got a better chance of
getting them on the phone the night.
I don't think he talked to me.
I fell.
Oh Shit I've talked about is
perfume ads is it looks bad ass,
world war z and maybe those perfume
man's fucking do it for me though.
Have seen them now.
Might be the Douchey is commercial world
has ever known next to Stephen Dorff
electronic cigarette
commercial right there.
Like what?
He needs the money.
Well,
you know,
the only thing that I leave for him,
his maybe he puts that money
to use in some positive way.
He's very active.
I know a lot of stuff both
in America and abroad,
so it could be that,
you know,
they were going donate a shitload
of money to something and he did it,
but it's chanel number five.
It's like such a Dorky,
but it's good to bring this up anyway
because I wanted to talk to you about
perfume because it's fucking hilarious.
Where it all came from.
Oh yeah.
I cover.
This stinks.
This is not the green.
That commercial using
conjunctive can chunk now.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Put the actual one man.
I don't want to see you.
GotTa you gotTa.
See his stupid face,
I doing it,
uh,
for the.
Yeah,
what's ridiculous.
It's the most ridiculous commercials
of all time because it's a guy who's a
fucking multimillionaire millionaire
that you noticed and wear the stupid,
Stinky Shit.
His wife as much money as he does and
he's done a little chanel number five
commercial and somebody has videos of
him sucking a million bucks or something.
That's how they did it.
It's something missing or they,
you know,
they promise to cure aids.
This is,
it really ends.
But we go on.
The world turns.
When we turned with it,
the world turns.
We turned.
Plans disappear.
Dreams take over
whenever I go.
There you are.
I love my faith.
Number five.
That's a fucking goddamn
Saturday night live sketch.
Okay.
Wow.
That does seem like a parody
of a commercial starring.
It also seems like a
parody of tree of life.
Did you see that movie?
Yes.
No,
I didn't know.
That's the Tom Hanks one with Brad Pitt.
It's directed by the guy who did the,
uh,
he's a very interesting directory.
Does like one movie every
10 years or something.
I can't remember his name right now.
This is not the interconnected lives.
What does well,
no,
that's the atlas.
The cloud atlas.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
No,
this,
this is like,
it is really trippy though.
It's like there's all this.
It'll have A.
Brad Pitt is a father,
a couple of kids.
I'm sure most of your listeners
know what I'm talking about it.
He's a well known director.
He did a really funky movie
about the Pacific Theater,
World War Two with Sean Penn in it.
Um,
and,
and um,
and uh,
the guy from Saturday night fever,
a gay guy bathhouses dare you,
the gay guy.
How about the amazing dancer,
like a really talented
actor from pulp fiction
suck dick and nanosecond to
know who is talking about.
You were playing charades.
I would applaud.
Anyway.
Yeah.
So that was,
that seemed like a parody of that movie.
There it is,
like the sun bursting and there's
this real slow visuals and yeah,
I don't know what the
fucking motivation was,
but it's preposterous.
Just completely ridiculous commercial.
The idea behind the perfume itself,
it's very fascinating though.
I don't like it.
I've never liked it.
I don't mean there's like a couple
like oils that girls can put on.
I think that smells kind of cool,
but generally I like the
way people smell in a clean,
you know,
and that's why perfume was invented.
People weren't fucking clean,
they were dirty,
stinking animals that
we're scared of water.
And that's also why spices
were so valuable during
those centuries of the spice
spices.
Pepper black pepper was worth more than
because the food was rotting so they
would spice the shit up.
So you couldn't taste.
How horrible did a lot of people die
from horrible digestive issues back then?
Uh,
well yeah.
In the medieval period,
a lot of people were dying from all sorts
of nastiness related to the nastiness
of the food,
but also the fact that they were shitting
in the street and there's no sewage
and everything.
But what's interesting,
I think this is like cutting
edge medical research.
Is that thing still
playing in the background?
In the background there?
Yeah,
I've heard it since the
movie was on just now.
What is the for your ipad?
You Fuck Jesus.
Brian.
I thought I was going crazy again.
Uh Oh.
Is it cutting edge medical
research I think is going to.
You're probably tuned into this because
of the body hacking and all that.
The,
the microflora of the stomach.
Yeah.
Really interesting.
So in those days people
would have had really robust,
uh,
intestinal flora to deal with all that.
The bacteria that you're absorbing
your system on a daily basis,
which dogs have supply dogs drink
water and people who live in India.
And you know,
I spent a lot of time and I went
swimming in a fucking lake in India.
I don't know what I was.
Do not have the science channel.
No.
Do not have discovery.
Do you not watch those things where people
come back with fucking football sized
parasites growing inside
of their head do this,
was,
this was a long time ago and I,
I was young and invincible,
but a lot of stupid shit.
Nothing.
You Got Lucky and I've
been healthy as shit,
you know,
I'm like the guy who never gets sick.
Maybe that's what it is.
I.
Well,
I think honestly,
I,
when I was traveling a lot in
Asia and Latin American stuff,
I took a lot of
acidophilus and raw garlic.
Talk about body smells,
man.
I ate so much raw garlic and uh,
and the raw garlic is good.
It keeps him skeeto so away they don't
like the smell of garlic and it comes out
through your skin.
It keeps women away too.
I found I'm not Italian women.
Yeah.
This is accepted Italian men.
Keep the Italian.
But uh,
yeah.
And I say that,
but the ball show a different story.
Are we going to put
our balls on the table?
Italian balls.
The balls are large.
They're the director.
I think it's more of a species.
I mean there is some cultural,
there is evidence that
Asian balls are smaller.
Um,
I am started talking Spanish.
They're quite a bit smaller than a black
balls and white balls or somewhere in
the middle
being very sort of.
I don't know if that's
politically incorrect to say,
but it's,
it seems to be true.
And my wife has,
I don't think I told you this story last
time because Sylvia was here last time,
um,
couple of years into our relationship.
Uh,
one night we were hanging out with a
friend in Barcelona smoking a joint and,
and uh,
this friend,
he's a funny guy,
he was giving me a hard time by
giving her a hard time essentially.
And so he was saying about,
Kyla,
you're so innocent,
you know,
you were in medical school and then you
were married all these years and you
know,
you hook up with Chris when you're 40,
you know,
you're just starting to see the
world as Chris's corrupting you.
Right.
And he said,
you're so innocent,
you probably think Chris has a big Dick.
And she said,
well,
no,
I,
I've inspected a thousand penises.
And we were like,
well,
she said,
yeah.
When I was doing that research for the
World Health Organization in Africa,
I had to inspect the
thousand penises and Vaginas.
It turns out.
I mean,
I knew she had done this research,
but I didn't know it involved
actually holding the Cox,
you know?
Yeah.
And so we loved to no gloves,
gloves,
because account then sort of counts.
It doesn't matter me.
I mean if I were going to be
uptight about shit like that,
believe me,
I'd be in a different business,
but a,
the funny thing was he was like,
but you know,
she's hot and she was 27
or something at the time.
And you're like,
what about erections?
And she just laughed and she said,
Oh yeah,
you just flick.
So Casella sort of like the anti
fluffer she knows how to bring it down.
There's like you flick right under
the head and the erection is gone
immediately.
Really try it when you get home.
Sounds annoying just to
annoy the shit out of him.
But somewhere out there there's
a guy that wouldn't stop me.
I like a little flicking.
So,
uh,
so she can prove she's one of the
rare individuals that seeing the broad
spectrum of the racist.
And she says,
well,
she seen a thousand Africans.
It's all apps.
That was all an hour.
Okay.
So it was all African people.
So it's a thousand Africans and me,
that's her,
her pool.
Oh yeah,
she's not impressed.
I haven't asked.
I don't even ask.
I don't want to know the answer.
That's funny.
What a Douche bag friend you have,
by the way.
I would cut that guy off
just the way it communicates.
Is he a dickhead?
He's a strange dude actually.
He's a jazz musician who went to,
grew up and went to college
in Philadelphia at Temple,
which is 98 percent black and he's white.
I'm Jewish.
He's like a hairy dark skin,
Jewish guys,
big tall guy.
And he talks like an inner
city Philadelphia black dude
and he sounds wonderful,
but he,
he's not doing it.
He's not racist.
Like he just,
he grew up with these guys and,
and you know,
you learn to sort of communicate
the way your community communicate.
But it could be awkward because he would,
you know,
as much as he would use
the n word liberally.
Really?
Yeah.
Among like a white crowd or,
and with his black friends who knew him,
but then it would get weird if we were
at a party or something and he'd be like,
Yo,
mom was like a fucking idiot.
What are you hanging out with
this guy for a long time?
Making fun of you
for having a regular size to your wife.
What?
Did douchebag dropping bombs.
Yeah,
bring them to my parties.
sounds like a treat.
He knows I love white
guys who talk black to.
Oh,
one of my favorite things.
Can't get enough of them in my life.
That's what you really want to go to.
If you're really confused about the world.
He needs a confidant.
Need someone?
Yeah.
You to go to a white guy who talks black.
Yeah,
but I mean it happens.
Hey,
look at all these kids with their pants
hanging down around their asses and
showing gang signs and you know,
flicker photos and what are you doing?
That pants
hanging around your.
Your ass means one thing.
You don't know how to check leg kicks
because I guarantee you one more tie at
all.
You wouldn't have your
fucking pants hamper.
Your someone who's just
going to kick your legs.
There's nothing you can do about it.
Your buckles over your Dick.
He can't move your hips.
Right?
Going to get into,
what did you say?
Look at those kids with their baggy
pants and their liquor photos,
the gang signs and their flicker
for the gang signs in their flicker,
flicker.
They really put the gang signs online
and you see these kids from Pacific
palisades.
It's like
there is an issue with that.
Those kids that grow up in those
really rich places where they want to
overcompensate because of the fact that
their parents are so not street and they
get like inner mixed with inner city kids.
They get shipped there and then they
want to prove their worth and I actually
had a friend who had a kid who went to a,
one of those Pacific
Pacific palisades or Malibu,
but one of those high
schools and he's like,
you'd be fucking amazing how bad it was.
They had to pull the kid out of there
because there's constant drugs and
violence and chaos and craziness and the
all a massive amount of kids in those
areas that grow up.
And I.
It kind of makes sense
if you think about it,
is people that have a fuckload of money,
a lot of them also,
they have issues with pills where
they have pills at home or um,
there,
there's a shallow sort of,
um,
materialistic vibe to the family and uh,
it gets,
it gets distributed to the kids and then
the kids start doing a lot of pills.
It's like it was Malibu or
one of those high schools.
I can't really wish I could remember,
but they were snorting oxies.
It was like a big issue.
You
know,
I've heard about that
in thousand oaks too,
that they have a problem with the girls.
Dylan has been quite a few girls
that have gotten in trouble for doing
oxycontin's.
They're doing heroin and they're doing
it in high school and these are really
wealthy neighborhoods,
wealthy areas.
But these people probably never
around for their fucking kids.
And if you've got enough
money to buy $9,000,000 house,
you work your Dick off,
you know,
you probably are not around that much.
Yeah.
I don't see how kids
are raised by Nannies.
Many cases.
Yeah.
Especially in those dual career household
when your wife works her ass off as
well,
you're both working your ass off all
day and then you're trying to become
parents at night and it's a fucking grind.
That's a hard grind.
You know,
if you leased a lot of poor people,
they involve their families in that grind,
you know,
they bring in the grandmother or you know,
they live in a neighborhood where a lot
of family members nearby and they can
sort of take turns taking care
of all the children together,
which actually turned out to be healthier
as long as it's not a high crime area
on that.
See that relates back to three history.
Yeah.
You know,
this whole idea and Kasota grew up in
Mozambique and she talked about like,
you know,
at night and nobody worried
about where you were.
Your parents didn't worry about
where you are wherever you were.
Somebody there are some adults,
they're taking care of you being cool,
you know,
you could eat dinner at somebody else's
house and come home later or sleep
there.
You look for like whatever.
It sounds.
So unity,
Utopian.
Yeah.
But yet,
not because nobody wants
to live in Mozambique,
you know,
no one here happened in math.
You say that,
oh,
but it's the Brazil in
Beverly Hills and say,
Hey,
who wants to go to Mozambique?
They going to go,
bitch,
are you crazy?
I'm not going to move to Mozambique.
I speech and you're like,
you could just let your kids
go and no one needs to worry.
Like,
fuck you.
What are you going to let your
kids go at night in Africa?
Are you fucking crazy?
No one's gonna believe that's the truth,
man.
So what is it like you said,
it's like the Brazil.
I haven't been to Mozambique.
So you're talking shit,
I'm talking shit.
But my wife grew up there so I hear a
lot about it and she was just there a
couple months ago and she said,
and it's like eight
percent economic growth.
It's Africa is booming right now because
the Chinese are buying up all the
natural resources that buying up land.
It's,
it's happening.
Wow.
Yeah.
In Mozambique's,
you know,
famous for their amazing
beaches and seafood.
And it's,
it's like a pretty raw,
beautiful spot on earth.
Wow.
Yeah.
Africa is a trip you fucking place,
man.
The idea of leaving the kids
just wandering around and
Africa are two lions and
Mozambique.
Yeah.
In fact,
she had a.
She had a German shepherd
who got that got eaten by
a lion when she was a kid.
Rice.
Yeah.
Mountain lions are scary lions
way scarier than mountain lion.
Nobody gets away from the lines.
But you know what kills
most people in Africa?
Hippo fucking ants over.
Really answer a motherfucker.
That's not a good way to.
There's video.
I saw once of ants eating an elephant
and they were going up the elephant's leg
into its ear.
Oh No.
And they were essentially
attacking this elephant,
eating an ear first,
just going right through the ear.
And there wasn't a Goddamn thing
the elephant can do to stop it.
Oh man,
that's not in Alaska.
You get that with mosquito.
Yeah,
I've seen that on a horrible.
I've never experienced it live,
but I've watched those,
um,
those Alaska sustenance shows those.
Um,
have you ever seen those shows?
Saw one or two.
Yeah.
Where they put these like a reality.
No,
no,
no.
These are actually people that live there.
They're uh,
they're these people that.
There's a bunch of different ones.
There's one of them's called Yukon
man and the other one's called Alaska,
the last frontier and,
and they're essentially these people
that live in these very small hunting
communities,
hunting fishing communities,
and they make no income other than furs
that they occasionally get and they have
three months of summer where they're
all just frantically trying to gather up
resources and then they
locked down for seven,
eight,
nine months.
It's crazy to watch.
And these people in the summertime,
they're dealing with fucking
swarms of mosquitoes,
like aggressive,
desperate mosquitoes.
They're like an inch across and they
know they only have a couple of months so
they just go for it.
Yeah,
I remember,
you know when the dusk,
when the mosquitoes come
out and you can see a swarm,
you're setting up your tent,
you know.
And like,
I remember setting up my tent and like
every second moving my shirts so they
couldn't get in through the shirt,
you know,
I had to keep moving the shirt
while I'm setting up the tent.
And then you get in
there and you can hear.
It's like hail banging against
the side of the tenant.
You can hear them banging on the tent.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
they're,
they're little helicopter.
What the fuck did people do
before they figured out tense?
Uh,
well the Eskimos,
I believe that they smeared
fat on their skin that would,
certain kinds of fat would keep the
mosquitoes off them and they've got all
sorts of really clever adaptations,
you know,
we,
we sort of assume that
we would be helpless,
but that's because we didn't grow
up there and our culture didn't,
you know.
So there's,
you know who Wade Davis is a,
he's a,
he's an anthropologist.
He's written a bunch of books.
Really interesting guy.
He's like anthropologists in residence
at the Smithsonian in Washington.
He wrote a book called the wayfarers
I think was his last book about
traditional,
like,
about how these guys could
navigate across the Pacific,
just looking at the stars and the color
of the water and smelling and whatever
they'd.
Anyway,
he,
uh,
one of the stories he tells us about this,
Eskimo guy,
old guy and the family sort of took
the keys to the car away from him.
Like you can't go anymore.
They were afraid he would go out and die
the traditional way when Eskimo people
got old,
they would like wander
off into the ice and die.
So as not to be a burden to the family.
Right.
And he was a traditional guy and they
were worried that he would take the snow
machine out and just die out there
somewhere or hurt himself hunting or
whatever.
So they had this whole intervention.
And so that night he goes out,
gets out of the house,
takes a shit in his hand,
forms the shit into a knife,
blade spits on it and the spit is
freezing along the edge and he hones that
down.
So he gets a nice sharp
edge with his sped,
takes his shit knife,
kills a dog or a couple of dogs and takes
their ribs and makes us a sled out of
it.
And with the sinews and whatever
other pieces of the dogs,
you know,
he knew all this stuff from his childhood,
hooks up a couple of other dogs to
the sled and he takes off into this,
into the snow on his,
you know,
sled with his shit knife.
Wow.
Oh my God.
That might be the most of the
same story I've ever heard.
And they're so clever.
You know how they killed polar bears.
I know they take blood
and put it on a blade.
I know that method.
That was actually wolves.
The wolves would lick the blade and uh,
we would,
uh,
they would cut themselves to death,
similar kind of thing.
What they would do is they take a little,
they'd make a wooden box
and they would take a seal,
a rib and sharpen the
two ends of the seal rib.
And they're pretty flexible.
They bend it and stick it into the box,
right?
And then they'd pour melted fat into the
box and let it solidify freeze and then
they knock it out.
So you've got a fat cube with this
flexed to bladed thing inside it.
And they leave that in the snow.
Polar bear come along,
swallow it,
and opens in the polar bear.
Wow.
And they just follow the blood
drops and it would kill them.
Yeah.
Because internal hemorrhaging.
How long did it take to kill him?
I Dunno,
I just remember that.
I mean,
there are stories like
that all over the world.
You know,
the Indian monkey trap,
the East Indian monkey.
No,
I don't know how interested your readers
or your listeners that system is.
And this is a good metaphor to.
I always remember this one.
They would take,
um,
same thing,
take a box with a hole about a little
smaller than a fist in the Mug,
in the box.
And they put a mango in the box and
then hammer it shot and tight to a tree.
So the mango starts rotting,
the monkey smells it.
Monkey comes along,
can stick his hand in and feel the mango,
but he can't get his hand out as long
as he's holding onto the mango and they
won't let go of the mango.
All they have to do is let
go and they could leave,
but they've got the mango in
their hands and they won't let go.
And so the guy comes
around to check the traps.
There's the monkey standing
there with his hand in the box.
Hit It on the head.
You got your monkey.
Whoa.
So it was something about greed there.
That's an awesome story.
That is a perfect metaphor to.
Yeah,
that's amazing.
Wow.
Let go of the mango.
That's my advice.
Yeah,
that's a good.
That should be a t shirt.
Not a bumper sticker.
A bumper sticker.
Bad showed good shit.
It's a better bumper.
He said Shit.
Knife is a crazy story.
The guy killed a dog with
a frozen piece of shit.
How stupid was that?
Dog
was sleeping there.
This guy came up,
my man,
he got shit,
man.
What the fuck are you doing?
Dogs Love Shit.
Where you at?
Where are you going to talk people into
shitting in their hand or stuff like
that.
Wasn't that one of your,
um,
I forgot I did.
I talked to you about this.
No,
no.
Um,
I believe you talked to Duncan.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
We were talking about um,
about wiping,
wiping yourself and about how weird it
is that we sort of like smudge tissue
over our assholes after we shit.
And then in other countries that we
consider these people to be savage,
they wash their hand,
you know,
and they wash their ass with their
hand and water and we'd like that.
It's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
exactly.
And it's the reason why your left hand
is the inappropriate hand to shake hands
with and already in the Arab and.
Yeah.
And that they,
they always clean with their left hand.
The Shit experiment.
Did you actually make people do that?
I didn't know.
Know what happened.
I pussied out to fucking Ted again
to ted get involved with bitches.
No balls.
No Shit.
You're out of here.
Do you want in the call?
Yes or no?
It just took down a couple more
videos recently of WHO's here,
I'll find it,
but then they put the hancock
and sheldrake ones back
up on the different part
of the site.
He ever took them down.
Totally.
They took them off of one part and they
put it on another part and they put it
up with a disclaimer because they
felt like that there was poor science.
There was bad,
so pseudo science,
which if if the scientists
can prove it makes sense,
but I think that if you.
You're going to invite someone to talk
and you're going to say that they have
pseudoscience.
I said at the very least you
should allow them to have a,
an appropriate response
or allow them to a debate.
You know them on the
merits of this science.
Exactly.
Because I don't know who's
right or who's wrong.
Well,
the anonymous scientific
panel that they use,
that's what I think is bullshit because
they've got a lot of mainstream people
who are going to say,
you know,
whatever Iowasca is bullshit,
but you know,
let let sheldrake debate that.
Or in that case it was hancock.
I think he was talking about Iowasca,
you know,
or get a Andrew Weil who's an expert,
ms or a way Davis Actually
Wade Davis and Andrew,
while we're both graduate students,
have Richard Evans
shelties,
who was probably the most important
bio,
sorry,
botanist of the 20th century.
He's the one who discovered the plants
behind and named the plants behind
Iowasca and La.
He did his graduate work on God.
He never.
He was a very sort of
straight guy himself.
He never took any of this stuff,
but he discovered dozens of
psychoactive plants in the Amazon.
He was down there like 20 years
years.
That sounds all great.
I mean,
that's absolutely great for expanding
people's knowledge on the subject,
but in their particular situation,
what was kind of disturbing
was that on the website of Ted,
the accusations that they had or the
reasons that they had for censoring
Hancock's work,
he asked them specifically
site where I said,
this site where I apply this,
this is not what I said.
So he was saying that they sort of made
this justification that didn't sort of
jive with his talk.
Now Rupert Sheldrake,
who I think is a bit more
controversial in his,
his statements,
what,
what Hancock is trying to say is that
Iowasca has had this profound effect on
humanity and it's based on his own
actual personal experiences taking it,
the experiences of other
people that have taken it.
The I,
the idea being that this indigenous
population was not the only peoples that
have discovered psychedelic plants,
but then in fact there's a cave art
that details people in altered states of
consciousness also details what they
believe to be certain psychedelic
substances and that it's most
likely responsible for a lot of art.
Um,
and I think that's a pretty
reasonable thing to say.
And if you don't think it's reasonable,
the only thing I could say is I doubt
you've had any psychedelic experiences
because psychedelic experiences would
be incredibly profound to monitor
primitive man and to state any best.
Seems to me that you're not being honest.
You're ignorant.
You're either ignorant to the effects of
these things or you're not being honest
about the effects of these things because
you're worried about the perception
that mainstream academia,
that most people in the media,
when you start talking about mushrooms,
they think you're a silly person.
You're a fool is again,
right?
That's the institution determining
the information that's allowed to flow
through that institution.
Yeah.
I interviewed,
um,
Charles grobe a couple of
weeks ago who was at Ucla.
He's a psychiatrist at Ucla who uses a
silicide and I think he's also used mgma
in psychotherapy with people who
have end stage cancer to help them.
It's been very effective in helping them
deal with the fear of death because of
the sort of transcendent transcendent
experience that often accompanies these
substances.
They feel a sense of
union with the university.
They lose a lot of that,
you know,
I'm just my body feeling which
helps them deal with death.
So transfer that to what saying about
I'm a hunter gatherer.
People are pre agricultural people around
the world or post agricultural people
so much in India and,
and a lot of,
uh,
the,
the ulysses,
you know,
the Elisa and fields in ancient Greeks.
A lot of these rituals
were apparently based on,
um,
Amanita Muscarella,
which is a highly hallucinogenic.
It's the red mushroom with the
white spots in Alice in wonderland.
And Yeah,
silence,
Santa Claus connection.
Very famous.
Exactly.
The AMANITA Mascara is.
So has that been proven?
Is that.
No,
that's,
it's a theory that was
proposed by Gordon Wasson who,
um,
uh,
this is all stuff you can
like mind Stanley on Saturday,
he was like,
Stanley met a woman,
the Shaman in Mexico who brought
mushrooms into the Western world.
I'm Maria Sabina.
Maria,
I think.
Is there any,
um,
any way that the point
I was making is that,
you know,
here's this guy using this stuff to
alleviate the fear of death with dramatic
results.
And yet,
as you say,
it's still considered fringe.
Although relating back to our earlier
conversation about institutions being in
the state of crisis,
because people sort of recognize the
false values and these institutions,
the government finally
allowing researchers.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's a pretty radical findings.
Uh,
the John Hopkins Study on
Psilocybin and behavioral change,
how it just one trip affected people's
behavior and personality is positively 20
years later.
And,
and what Hancock was talking about
with specifically the effect of some
hallucinogens on addiction.
Yes.
And he was using his own
personal addiction to cannabis.
He had a lifelong history
of abuse as he called it,
with cannabis.
Say,
sorry to interrupt you,
but just the last point on that I,
I didn't listen to sheldrake's thing,
but I did listen to Hancock and he
framed the whole thing in I think very
scientific terms.
He said,
this may have caused this
leap forward in consciousness.
This may have been
responsible for this and that
it's absolutely a fascinating
possibility to consider.
And the only people in my opinion
that would not consider it are again,
people that have had no experiences with
it or people that were worried about
the mainstream academic approval.
And so they step back and go,
oh,
this is preposterous,
you know,
this is not,
it's an incredibly powerful experience.
It cannot be denied.
And,
and yet for whatever reason,
we've lumped it into
silliness and I really,
I struggled with now,
or criminality.
Yes,
even more scary than silliness.
Um,
I've,
uh,
really it's really boggled my mind.
And the only thing that makes
sense is that it's ignorance.
It's the illegality of it,
which was a hoist onto the American
people in the 19 seventies when they were
just trying to control this mass
change in culture that had happened so
radically between the fifties,
the sixties.
And we lost a lot of information in that.
And we also got a lot of
people that were scared,
scared about going to jail,
scared about losing their jobs and that
all that fear and ignorance clouds the
actual argument.
It clouds the actual facts that
surround these weird substances.
And they,
they're not the cure all.
They're not,
they're not,
they're not for everybody.
But what they are is incredibly
powerful experiences.
I think that can be denied and to deny
the impact of one of the most amazing
trends in dental experiences that a human
being can ever possibly experience and
the fact that it's an orally active thing,
that it grows all over the place
where these people absolutely lived.
To deny the connection seems really silly.
It doesn't.
It seems like you're.
You're being a fool and you're.
You're ignoring information
and people all over the world
who have access to these plants,
wherever you find them,
consider them to be the
greatest gift of the gods.
Yes,
and then you've got our culture that says,
if you get caught with
an ounce of Siliciden,
mushrooms are 100 hits of
acid at a grateful dead show.
You go to prison under minimum mandatory
sentencing for longer than second
degree murder.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
That's complete pure insanity
that that's insanity,
but what's even more and sanity is to me
that people in positions of prominence
academically who will talk on these
subjects have not had this experience and
I'm like my God,
your children,
and it sounds so arrogant to say that,
but someone who's like talking about the
negative effects of psychedelic drugs
that hasn't had psychedelic drugs will
feel like a child after he has a mushroom
chip.
He will feel like a full.
You will feel like you the dumbest person
in the world to have ignored that and
Pooh poohed that takes
six grams of mushrooms,
get in an isolation tank and tell me
you don't have some regrets for how you
look at that shit before.
Right?
They're not having it and it's these.
These are the same people that
are pulling these things down.
I guarantee you the people that have
had profound mushroom trips are not
interested in,
in,
in silencing this Graham
Hancock a war on consciousness,
which originally was called beating.
I think something about the green bitch.
He reasonably could
defeating the Green Bitch,
which was his addiction,
cannabis and how the.
The,
the IOWASCA helped him see who he was,
his,
uh,
abusive relationship and it seems really
fascinating guy because he's not down
on marijuana at all.
He's sort of attributes it to his own
abuse of it and using it as a crutch
instead of using it to enhance,
you know,
so he had whatever
addictive issues he had.
That's how they mean that.
And that is a real issue with addiction,
right?
It's like,
it's not necessarily the substance of the
biologic triggers what's going on with
you that makes you obsess
with scratch tickets.
Who's
The guy?
I'm the British actors,
Guinea comedian.
Really Guy Sleeping with Russell brand,
Russell brand.
Thank you.
Should play.
This is what happens when
we get all that back.
I remember the Guy
fucking point me my brain,
I'll just stick in the air
massage guy likes massages.
Russell brand wrote a thing recently
about addiction and he said something I
thought was really wise.
He said drugs weren't my problem,
drugs were my answer to my problem.
Uh,
and it's,
it's exactly what you just said in that.
I agree completely.
Drugs aren't causing the addiction.
You've got an addiction,
it can manifest as you know,
in marijuana,
in gambling and jerking off and you know,
a million different ways and if you
locate the problem in the substance then
you'll never solve the problem
because that's just a symptom,
right?
There is a physiological issue
that goes along with that as well.
So because there's two
types of situations,
there's the gambling situation where
you're sort of getting addicted to the
response,
but then there's a real like,
like an oxycontin thing.
Like I have a friend who had
a back operation and then
after his back operation
they throw them on some oxygen and
he was fucked up for a long time.
He started getting prescriptions from
more than one different doctor and he was
a mess.
He just went,
I just went crazy spiral
and it was absolutely a
physiological addiction because
before that he really didn't exhibit
crazy addictive or impulsive behaviors and
they were manifested itself with these.
But it's situation
changed with that pain and the gambler
is also getting a chemical a high.
Yes,
you know,
the brain is releasing
endorphins or whatever it is.
And in that case,
so there,
you know,
you could argue they're both
physiological on some level,
but yeah,
the point is that there is some,
in his case it was chronic pain.
In another case it could be ptsd,
it could be a fucked up childhood,
it could be whatever.
That is a funny way to look
at it that I never think I,
I don't think I ever looked at it that
way before that it is still a chemical
addiction.
It's just sort of an endogenous one.
Yeah.
That's funny.
I never thought about it that way.
I was knocked it off
thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
orgasm as people jerk off in
front of the computer all day.
They're get there some
we're talking to you.
Yeah.
That's you.
That's you,
you motherfucker.
You know you are.
Yeah.
That's.
Well that's also sort of just
becomes like impulsive it,
like it was not even a
reward sometimes it just,
just sort of repeat a pattern.
Like you're stuck.
You got to scratch her when you stop.
And that's what addiction is.
It hurts when you stopped.
You were talking earlier,
we were talking about primitive so
called primitive societies and stuff.
You reminded me of this amazing story I
read recently where this BBC team went
into Papa New Guinea way back some river
and they were doing a special on these
very so called primitive
people back there,
you know,
no Internet,
no nothing.
And one of the guys,
uh,
after they'd finished filming,
one of the guys said,
well,
you've,
we've shown you our world.
Why don't you bring me to your world?
I'd like to see your world.
So when he was back
in London,
he talked to some people and they said,
well,
okay,
we'll fund it.
That would be an interesting thing.
Bring these guys into London and you know,
and do this whole thing
sort of in reverse.
What's that?
It's a sitcom.
Yeah,
exactly.
Realities.
Dude's fucking reality shifts.
Take them in London.
Yeah.
So the Jersey shore for the UK.
So,
so this guy,
his concern was that once
this guy saw the modern world,
he would never want to go home.
So he called up an
anthropologist and he said,
look,
I'm really worried about this.
I'd like to do this,
but.
And the anthropologists
send you arrogant asshole.
You really think this guy's going to be
so impressed by London that he'd never
want to go back to his friends
and family and you know,
his whole world and all
that just calm down.
That's not going to happen.
Right?
Trust.
So they fly this guy,
if you guys up to London or
they take them all around,
show them,
you know,
whatever,
all these different things.
And one of the things they really
wanted to see was something like a,
an archery range.
So they took them to this archery range
and they were so fascinated by the
arrows that had feathers on
the era of the flushings.
Yeah.
Their feathers didn't have arrows.
Arrows in the federal.
Sorry,
there's didn't have feathers.
So anyway,
at the end of this whole
experience of being in London,
the only thing they wanted to take back
was this knowledge of how you put the
feathers on the air.
They weren't interested in.
No.
At the worlds.
That story is that London ain't Tahiti,
Tahiti,
anthropologists,
and be like,
yeah,
they're not going
to get him on his shit.
Drunk white leg paper
eating fish and chips.
They're gonna.
Want to get the fuck out of there
as quickly as they got their
new kitties.
That trip,
man,
[inaudible] New Guinea
has those semen warriors.
That's one of the weirdest and I was going
to bring that up earlier when we were
talking about these patterns that sort
of develop in these tribal societies.
One of the most bizarre ones is these,
they take young boys away from their
mother when they're like six or seven and
they live with men that are the like an
anal father and anal son like that's how
they.
They they,
they call it and the man just
fucks these kids and they.
They believe that the kid has to swallow
and ingest semen into his body in order
for him to grow up strong and be a
man and that they only use women for,
for procreation or that this entire
culture of thousands of people is wrapped
around little kids,
sucking guys dicks to
grow old to grow strong.
Fucking.
That is.
That is one of the craziest ones I've
ever written or read rather than.
Yeah,
that somehow or another they
convinced thousands of people
into that one.
But what's the of that?
Oh,
who knows?
You know,
they don't want nobody to know,
but you find stuff like that motherfucker.
Just
one pope can just ruin
a whole damn religion.
Maybe they were missionaries because
you know that happened in the Amazon.
There's a case of Liza was his name.
He's a French missionary.
He was the,
or an anthropologist.
He wasn't a missionary is an
anthropologist who studied under a,
the great French,
a Levy Strauss,
and he went to the Yanomami people in
Venezuela and he was fucking all the boys
and doing all this crazy shit and telling
them that this was the way it worked
in the world.
And you know,
he's still there.
I think he's still alive.
This part of the whole holy
and Shag non situation.
I don't know if you're familiar with that.
Yeah.
It's very controversial
stuff that happened.
Uh,
Shannon is,
he wrote the fierce people,
which is the best selling
anthropology book of all time.
And he was like a Hemingway Kinda guy.
And he just published a book recently
talking about trying to redeem his
reputation because it turns out like
what he did was he went to the Amazon in
the late sixties,
uh,
or the Orinoco really,
which is a tributary of
the Amazon in Venezuela.
And he was studying the
Yanomami people and um,
he wrote a thesis and calling them
the fierce people saying that they,
they killed each other at such high rates.
And this justifies this hobbsy and view
of the origins of human violence that
were really nasty and so we need these
governments and religions to keep us in
check and you know,
it's very political,
right?
But he was just saying it's anthropology,
but it resonated with the culture of
Vietnam was happening and there's all this
discussion of what,
why are we violent?
Is that our nature?
Or is it institutional,
you know,
the whole hippies versus
the institution debate.
So anyway,
he wrote this book and it was a huge
bestseller and he became super famous.
Turns out that when he
went into this area,
he brought lots of machetes and these
people didn't have lots of machetes.
They didn't have metal tools at all.
So he brings in the machetes and he starts
giving the machetes to certain groups
in exchange for their cooperation.
And his research was on a genealogy,
so he needed to get
the names of ancestors.
But it turns out that the Yanomami,
it's a great taboo to ever
say the name of a dead person.
So what he would do is say,
okay,
I'll give you this machete if you
tell me the names of the father and
grandfather have that guy
from that other village,
so he would bribe them
to get this information,
but that's a great taboo to say the names
of that guy's father or grandfather,
right.
So then he would go to the other village
and as a way to confirm whether the
information was correct,
he would say so and so over there said
your father and grandfather were blah
blah blah and blah blah blah.
And if they got really pissed off,
he knew it was correct.
So that would confirm his information.
Then they would break,
they would have all these wars and they
kill each other with these machetes.
And then he reported back saying,
Oh,
the Yanomami are very fierce destructive
war like people and this is the origins
of humanity and Yada Yada.
Ya fucking bullshit,
man.
Complete Bullshit.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
So there is a book called darkness and
El Dorado that came out a few years ago.
It was a big bestseller and
exposed a lot of this stuff.
And it also went further
and accused him of genocide,
him and this other guy,
neal,
for it accused them of using a vaccination
program as a way to sort of test
immune responses.
And that appears to be for.
That appears to have been true.
Right.
But the other stuff with the machetes
and sewing violence and all that,
and then reporting that their
station from the other guy.
The other guy.
Yeah.
That's true.
About fucking group of victimized people
trying to just get along and these
white people come along
and fuck everything up.
Yeah.
And they even.
I write about the insects,
the situation in sex at dawn and they,
even the Yanomami have
a special word called,
I think it's anthro,
which means like a crazy
destructive white person.
And so he's not even allowed
to go back to Venezuela.
He's barred from the country.
Wow.
Yeah.
I don't know why I was talking about that.
I don't remember what 10.
Doesn't matter.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's.
Well,
it's just the distortion of the,
our,
our image of these people and how
these crazy cultures can interrupt.
That might've been missionaries that cause
these guys to blow all these kids and
by the time,
oh,
that's what I was rather.
I mean,
you see these interesting sexual
practices all over the world and so they,
a lot of stuffs,
you know that.
When I was talking about that when last
night at a cocktail party in Venice
actually I was talking with this gay
guy and we were talking about how,
you know,
we think we know what it means to be gay,
but you look at a culture
like that and you say,
well,
are they gay?
I know they consider it to
be normal sexual development,
conventional,
you know,
that's what you do.
Or the Messiah,
the Messiah,
you know,
the herb's herdsmen new drink
blood and milk in Kenya.
They have a similar sort
of thing where the young,
younger boys go out on these long,
you know,
when they're out with the herds
for weeks or months at a time.
They go out with the older boys and
the older boys will have sex with them.
Not Anal sex,
but they'll um,
they'll put their penis between
the thighs of the younger boy.
That was how the room is that?
Yeah,
there's a name for that.
I can't remember the word
was specific word for it.
Either way.
It's still good.
Let them know.
Well,
that's the thing.
They would say it's not
because then they get older.
They marry a woman.
They have kids.
That's just normal growing up.
Normal fuckery.
Yeah.
I'm not.
I think once you know what
kind of a effect that has
on the young boys,
that's the thing.
If it's considered normal,
it doesn't knock it until you fight it.
Oh,
how dare you.
How dare you.
He was so proud of himself.
He was hanging out with
Hinchcliffe too long.
The,
um,
the,
the idea though that it's not going to
have an effect is only based on the fact
that they're going to do it to more
young boys and they're not going to
complain.
And that's,
uh,
one of the weird things about sexual
abuse is that it sort of re re manifests
itself in the victim and
they start to be become a,
they become
the,
the accuser.
I mean,
they,
they also become the perpetrator.
They,
in fact that,
that a guy I was speaking to recently
who identifies as gay,
he said to me,
I don't think I was born gay.
I think I'm gay because I was sexually
abused as a child by my stepfather from
the time I was three.
And we got into this
whole discussion of how,
um,
it's,
there's the term erotic plasticity and
how different it is for men and women in
men and males have other mammals.
There seems to be a developmental window
where we imprint something and that
window closes and if you got an
imprint that sticks with you for life,
which is why virtually
all fetishist sermon,
right?
There are a lot of men who will say,
well,
I can't get off unless you know,
there's latex or she's
wearing red high heeled shoes,
or she's got this or that.
Right?
You don't.
Women don't say that like women,
you know,
they're much more flexible
and adapt to the situation.
So the idea is that if during that
window you're imprinted with male,
male sex and pleasure involved with that,
then you could sort of like have that
as a fetish even though you were born,
you know,
you're sort of genetic components or
your brain development or whatever.
There are different
theories is heterosexual.
So there are different.
According to this idea,
there are different ways to be gay.
You can be born gay or you could be,
you could be gay as a fetish in a way,
you know,
but anyway,
related to what you were
saying about the trauma,
there's research showing that what
really causes the trauma is the shame
generated by the culture that boys who
are what we would call sexually abused or
girls who were sexually
abused at a young age.
Uh,
if there's not pain involved,
right?
If it's inappropriate
touching or whatever,
um,
the trauma comes about when they're told
that was really bad and they're told
that that's a horrible
thing that happened.
It doesn't necessarily come
about from the experience itself.
And I don't mean this as
to justify anything or
aren't there a variety of
different types of experiences?
Are these consensual and just innocent
or are these actual hold you down?
Rape.
That's what I'm saying.
It's physical
pains,
a whole different thing.
If it's just two little
kids diddling each other,
you know,
some mothers would say that's abuse.
That's a horrible,
oh my God,
what happened?
The best thing to do is just say,
hey,
nothing happened.
You know,
it's no big deal.
Right?
Um,
and there are psychological studies
showing that the lasting effects are
negligible and less.
It's framed as,
oh my God,
what happened?
That completely makes sense.
As does the framing thing,
the framing thing completely
makes sense as well,
that there's something happens in their
life and they just get imprinted and
that's been otherwise,
why would so many abuse victims
become abusers themselves?
You would think that like you,
the last thing you
would do is repeat that,
right?
Oh my God,
that's the thing that fucked
you up and ruined you.
You would say like,
man,
I would never want to do this to another
person and that would be how would we
would evolve.
So it seems like there's like a hitch
in the developmental process that allows
weird things just to be accepted
and become the standard,
right?
They become eroticized and associated
with pleasure and so you try to relive
them later.
There's a great experiment with,
um,
it happened in Scotland I think
where they took a one year,
they had like a herd of goats and a
herd of sheep and so they took all the
babies,
all the baby goats and put them with the
sheep and they took all the baby sheep
and put them with the goats.
So they were raised thinking
they were the other species,
right?
So all the goats grew up around the
sheep thinking I'm just a weird looking
cheap.
Right.
And the vice versa.
So the way till they got sexually mature
and started having sex and then they
switched them back.
And what happened was that the males
refused to have sex with their own species
because they had learned that none of
the male goats and learn like I fuck
sheep.
No,
I fucked goats.
The females were like,
yeah,
whatever.
You know,
they just sort of like went with it.
But the males refused.
They were stuck with it
because they were imprinted.
And that was it.
That is fascinating.
Yeah.
What the fuck,
evolutionary purposes that play.
Who knows?
That's a good question.
I don't know,
but it's,
it's a common mistake I would say in,
and I'm not saying just among people
reading books for the first time among
experts,
there's a mistake of thinking that
everything has an evolutionary function.
I say sometimes it could just be the,
the tide went that way
and that's what happened.
And there's a,
there's something Stephen Jay Gould,
the great evolutionary
theorist called spandrels,
which are things that look
like they have a function,
but they're actually sort of a
side effect of something else.
You know,
like the chin,
you know,
why did the Chin evolved the way it did?
Well,
we have a word for this
thing we call the chin,
but it's not actually a thing.
It's where the two jawbones fuse,
so it's,
it does,
you know,
it exists as linguistic concept,
but not necessarily as
a biological concept.
So they're,
they're weird,
you know,
they're murky waters.
You can get lost and when you're
looking at evolutionary stuff,
and he always advised people.
You always say,
what's the evolutionary function of that?
Be Clear on what that is and that it
actually would necessarily have an
evolutionary function.
You know,
I've always been fascinated by why
at the same time all over the world,
people who are human beings or you can
breed with each other but have such
incredibly varied ways of behaving and
that this has always been this way.
I'm really into this.
I'm Dan Carlin,
a podcast recently.
He's got this podcast called hardcore
history and he does this really detailed
history of the Mongols over like five,
five episodes and it's amazing.
It's amazing.
It's just fucking craziness.
The way these people just took over
Europe and just conquered and just the
madness and the how they were so different
from anyone that existed at that time
and that they were so extreme and intense,
but at the same time that they
lived somewhere in the Amazon,
there are a bunch of people do an
Iowaska eating fish and you know,
polyamorous people and it's amazing
that this all took place all along.
And during the same time.
Do you ever read the
travels of Marco Polo?
No.
You know the story.
He's like 14 hundreds or something
like that at 13 hundreds.
And he went to.
He was with the Mongols and he walked
all across Asia on the spice route with
his uncles.
And uh,
yeah,
he was with a,
I don't know if it was gang
con or Kubelet icon or which,
which of the Mongo kings it was.
And along the way talking
about interesting people,
he stayed with the most.
Well,
people of southwestern China
who still exists and uh,
apparently still have this
very interesting marital,
well,
not even marital sexual behavior where
both men and women are completely
autonomous.
Sexual beings,
you have sex with whomever you want.
There's no slut shaming,
there's no shame involved
with multiple partners.
Whatever you do,
what you want.
When a girl becomes sexually mature,
she gets her own room called a flower
room that has a door that opens into the
central courtyard of her mother's house
where she lives and also has a door that
opens into the street.
And so that girl from,
you know,
13,
14,
whatever,
sexual maturity,
she can let anyone.
She wants to come in and spend
the night in her room with her.
The only rule is he can't
be there for breakfast,
right?
So no,
no,
nobody's invited for breakfast,
get get out by sunrise,
but she can sleep with whoever she wants.
Then what happens when she gets pregnant
is that the child is cared for by
her brothers and her sisters.
So as a man,
your paternal responsibility
is to your sister's kids,
not to your biological child.
In fact,
biological fatherhood is,
is,
is a nonissue in this society is amazing.
Yeah.
Really interesting society.
It's,
it's the law in,
in um,
Marco Polo stayed with them and he
wrote about them and he thought typical
Italian,
right?
He thought that he was screwing these
women behind the men's backs and,
you know,
play Marco polos getting he was getting.
So he just thought he was slick.
He thought he was a cool guy,
but it turns out the women were just like,
Yo,
that's funny.
It is amazing.
When you think about the variables,
it's amazing when you think about the
variety of different cultures that evolve
simultaneously over the world and how is
it their environment that causes that?
Or is it,
this is a missionaries move in and
give them machetes and talk about their
ancestors.
I mean the various,
the various things that happen or.
So.
Um,
and I know I confuse those two stores.
The missionary and the researcher.
No,
it's all you mean.
Yeah.
And smallpox comes in and then
you get the ice ages and you know,
but I,
I,
I tend to be a materialist.
There's a book called cultural
materialism by Marvin Harris,
which is a great book.
And he wrote a more popular
book called Cannibals and Kings,
which covers some of the same stuff.
And He,
like,
he looked at things like why are some
societies cannibals and others aren't,
right.
So you've got the,
you know,
the clash of European societies and
the Aztecs and the mind and all that.
And so,
you know,
you can't say the Europeans
weren't blood thirsty,
you know,
crazy killers.
They just didn't eat what they
killed the people they killed.
Whereas the Aztecs were killing the
people that are eating the people they
killed.
Why is that?
Or why on some South Pacific islands
where the people cannibalistic and others,
they weren't right.
So what he did was he did a,
a materialistic analysis.
And what he found was that without
exception in the societies that were
cannibalistic,
there was no other source of protein
that didn't compete with humans for the
same food.
So like they didn't have pigs,
right?
Pigs will eat stuff.
Humans,
canny,
right?
So you can raise pigs without
feeding them your own food.
But dogs,
you feed them stuff you would
eat because dogs eat meat.
Right?
So in Mexico there was
nothing that they could raise,
no,
no animal that could be domesticated
that they could raise for meat.
And so that's why they eat the dead
people because they were protein starved.
Wow.
And then you apply that same thing to the
different islands in the South Pacific
and he found the same.
And American Indians,
native Americans in the harshest
climates were the ones that we're tending
towards cannibalism like
towards the Great Lakes,
like the,
uh,
the native American people
from the Great Lakes area.
Those are the ones that,
uh,
there's uh,
stories of
cannibalizing people.
Yeah.
And you also have.
Yeah,
in Midwinter Yeah,
sure.
But also in,
in that kind of thing,
you want to look at ritualistic
cannibalism versus like,
okay,
dinner time,
you know?
Yeah.
Because they,
they had some interesting torture
ceremonies as well in those Canadian Great
Lakes Iroquois,
kind of that.
It was an honor to be tortured to death.
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
Steven Rinella guy that
I was telling you about,
his book mediator,
I,
he told me some crazy stories about
the people that lived off the Missouri,
the Missouri River,
like in Montana and trappers and all
these different people that have these
conflicts with the Indians
and other would kill them.
And there was a lot of
cannibalism going on,
a lot more than I would've ever imagined.
It's because that's not really something
that gets brought up in high school
history or you know,
they don't,
they don't really tell you,
oh by the way,
occasionally used to eat people
as did the settlers and our,
you know,
the Donner Party,
North America itself is one of the most
spectacular examples of how quickly
things can change.
You're right,
if you stop and think about North
America just a thousand years ago,
just $1,000 anywhere in Europe.
1,000.
It's like there's still people,
man,
they're still the nuttiness.
There's still.
I've hung out in bars that were
more than a thousand years old,
I'm sure.
What is the oldest bar in,
um,
in London as they're like a bar.
That's when like the fucking,
I dunno,
Barcelona,
I could take you to them.
Uh,
how old are below them?
Well,
the oldest continually open
bar is from the 1700 I made.
I'll bother and I've
been there many times.
But the place I'm thinking of when,
when I've said the thousand years old,
it's a bar down in the Gulf decaux
section of Barcelona where one wall of the
bar is a Roman wall from the original
Roman building that was there.
So you're like leaning up against
the Romans while drinking your beer.
It's really cool.
Holy Shit.
Not America.
And that's 2000 years
old a thousand years ago.
No Manhattan,
no Los Angeles,
no Chicago,
no Atlanta.
Just stop and think of that alone.
Just what radical changes to the landscape
we've seen over the past few hundred
years.
We get a thousand thousand years ago.
You wind up in New York on
a boat and what are you,
what are you looking at?
Looking at some fucking wooden shacks.
The huddled up together
eating beaver pelts.
Fuck you.
Looking at
this thing has changed so fast.
I,
I met a guy at a wedding a
few years ago who was like,
one of the world's leading
experts on seashells.
Sounds Kinda boring,
right?
But we ended up talking about wampum
and he told me something I'd never read
anywhere,
which,
you know,
wampum writers made from seashells.
This was like the,
the name,
but I don't know what it
was that native Americans
used in the northeast.
Right when,
when the Dutch first arrived in the very
early days of New York is what reminded
me of it.
It was made from a particular type of
seashell that only grew in a certain area.
So like all currencies,
it had a very restricted source,
you know,
like gold or whatever,
beaver pelts or whatever it was.
It's,
by the way,
you know,
that's why 20 bucks,
that's deer skins.
That deer screens are used as
currency and the colonial period.
Yeah,
that's why we say 20 bucks.
Yeah.
But anyway,
so the Wampum,
they'd make these belts of wampum that
you could use to buy and sell things.
Right?
So the Dutch clever bastards that they
are figured out how they were making this
wampum and what sort of
seashells it was and they,
they learn to cultivate
that particular molecule.
They were basically printing,
you know,
counterfeit wampum.
Wow.
So they didn't even just rip off the
Indians when they bought Manhattan.
They bought it with fake money.
Holy Shit.
Fake Indian money.
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
They bought it with seashells.
And imagine how much your condo goes for
now and just think that the whole thing
went for seashells.
That's a change in the real
estate market right there.
You know what I love?
I lived in Manhattan for a few
years and last year I was there.
I worked in a construction site and
since we're just talking randomly
interesting things here,
the guy,
one of the laborers on the construction
site explain to me why the buildings are
really high in midtown and then they
go down and then they go back up and
they're high again down in Wall
Street and the financial district.
If you look at Manhattan from New Jersey,
you're from queens or
Brooklyn or whatever the.
I always thought that was just like
what you're saying is like there are all
these strange things that come together,
whether it's finance or you know,
whatever happens,
stand.
Somebody wanted to it here.
There it turns out,
no,
there's a logic to this
and the logic is that the,
the,
the rock that grant,
the geological rock comes up near the
surface at midtown and then it goes way
down again and that Anders Soho
in the village and all that,
and then it comes back up close
to the surface at Wall Street.
So to build a really tall building,
you have to drill,
anchor it into the rock.
So you can't do that where there's a lot
of dirt you'd have to like dig down so
far to get to excavate the whole.
So you can only build a 50 story building
where the bedrock is close to the
surface and you can anchor it into there.
Right?
So it's stable.
Totally makes sense.
So what you're seeing when you look
at that skyline is like an echo of the
geology of the island.
Wow.
Interesting.
That is a,
that is absolutely fascinating.
Um,
brings me up to this quote I was going
to bring up earlier when you talked about
Marshall Mcluhan.
A lot of folks don't know
Marshall Mcluhan was,
but he said a lot of amazing things
and one of the things he said,
I think it was either the fifties,
I think he said in the fifties,
he said that man becomes the
sex organs of the machine world.
That's beautiful.
The craziest statement ever.
Have you stop and think about
how premature it was and our,
our,
how precocious it was to say that in
whatever he said that in 1950 or 1960 and
look at what's going on now with our
symbiotic connection to technology.
The true machine that's taking over,
that's,
I'm writing that down because
I'm going to use that thing.
I thought about that so many times
without even having read his quote,
but I wasn't able to put it so eloquently
in my head because that if that the
faith look like a life form.
I mean I have skeletons in my garage.
It's an old Mac,
old shitty fucking like Tan thing
with the stupid rainbow apple on it.
I have one of those things.
It's like really old.
It's hilarious.
I look at it,
I'm like,
this is like a dinosaur,
so might as well be like a dead dinosaur,
dead useless thing and now you know,
we don't have dinosaurs anymore.
Now we got chickens,
you know,
now whatever.
I mean,
it really does seem like.
Yeah,
I wrote an article about the
future of sex for this European.
They called the European magazine.
It's,
I guess it's a German magazine,
but they publish in English as well.
He asked me to write this thing a few
months ago and I could have used that
McLuhan quote that was really good.
But I said like basically the way I see
the future of sex is peeling off in two
different possible directions depending
upon whether there's world collapse or
not.
And uh,
if there's not,
I see us as many people
do merging with machines,
what do they call it?
The singularity,
but also in terms of
sexuality that you know,
now we've got flashlights,
but in a few years we're going
to have holographic images.
We're going to have like the technology
is always driven by this sexual hunger.
There's a book called the erotic
engine where this guy argues that every
communication advance was driven
by money coming from orotic energy,
you know,
vhs tapes and then dvds and the Internet,
like all the first monies
coming in for porn,
you know,
even photography
first,
a adapters,
first time adapters like
html five and all that.
As soon as soon as people realized that
the iphone wasn't going to go with flash
and that a html five seemed like the
future when it comes to a animated things
online,
porn went right to it.
Sure.
You know,
whereas a lot of websites,
you still,
you go to it on an iphone and
it'll show you the adobe thing.
Not supported and not porn.
They figured out right
away I had him on the ball.
Yeah.
They gotta make it so you could
watch people fuck on your phone.
Yeah.
Isn't it amazing though
that that is a sort of,
again,
in the closet,
it's sort of a background sort of reality,
like all the banks in Miami
being funded by cocaine.
Everybody knows it,
but nobody talks about it.
Right.
You know,
why is there so many banks,
Miami?
Because that's where the
fucking cocaine came from.
Why?
Why is,
why is technology moving
towards html five?
Why is what,
what is online streaming technology?
Where's its roots?
Its roots are in people watching people.
Fuck.
That's where they got it down.
That's where they get really good
at it and that's where the money is.
And then that might.
I mean,
what percentage of that was responsible
for the development of the CD Rom?
What percentage of the.
You know,
how much I would like to know about the
erotic engine that he talks about all
that.
Yeah,
because before the Internet came along,
I mean how many people
bought movies as supposed to?
How many people bought dirty movies?
What was the share of the market?
Fucking chunk,
right.
Well,
Miss Cinemas,
the porn.
That was another thing from your book
that I found completely fascinating.
I didn't think about was how we have
this idea of corporate America not being
not profit profiting in porn,
but how in fact like chains of hotels are
like the biggest porn providers in the
world.
Yeah,
yeah.
They're making huge proportion of their
profits from those on demand movies.
Last week when I was in San Diego,
I literally went through the whole
entire list of porn because they were so
funny.
Titles.
It was probably 300 titles
that they just had their
and they're selling for like what,
20 bucks or $10,
whatever it is.
I mean that's pure profit
at a certain point,
you know,
and once they pay the licensing
fee off or whatever it is,
so them.
And you know what it was the other example
you had of people that were profiting
off point that you would not expect.
Yeah,
I don't remember.
I remember the,
the corporate thing you're talking about
and I think the corporation in question
might've been coca cola or somebody
owned by Mormons or something.
It was some like really
conservative public image,
but they were the biggest
supplier to the hotel chains.
Yeah.
And they were definitely
going to be hilarious.
Chick fil a is only into chickens
and Dixon Asad said the other day I
interviewed Nina Hartley from podcast.
She's really interested in
how to run away from her.
She was on Kevin Prayers podcast and as
soon as she's talking about how she only
has sex with gloves on,
I was like,
bitch,
you lost me.
I lost me bitch.
I got to go.
She only had sex with Linda fisting
and finger souls and plus these and she
doesn't want fingernails.
And I mean it makes sense,
but it's because she's
a goddamn professional.
I mean she's got the pro clinic goal.
Snap a rubber glove approach to sex.
She's also a nurse.
She has her own flashlight,
right?
She's got her own and resembles
a metal hitting a large mammal.
What you would get.
Nice Lady.
She's not freak.
She's.
Yeah,
she is smart.
She's an old hippie freak.
That's what she is,
you know?
Yeah.
But I got walk.
That's where I got to walk away.
We start talking about
I only have sex with gloves on.
Okay.
Last me gold bond on it.
And then I rub it,
she's not that old dude.
You made her like,
she's something past a MILF though,
right?
It's like we talked to.
She's a new categories.
Fifty three,
54,
somewhere in there.
Still fucking throwing down.
Broken down.
She's an educator.
She's good.
You're talking about gloves mean we had
a friend of mine told me this story.
He,
he was with a woman who is polyamorous.
Right?
And so he,
he,
you know,
whatever they're going out to dinner
and he gets a text from her a few hours
before dinner saying,
look,
I'm,
I just want to be upfront about this
as polyamorous people off in art.
My agreement with my partner is,
um,
what,
what was the detail or the,
the agreement is no,
no,
uh,
intercourse,
so we can do whatever
else but no intercourse.
Right?
So He's thinking,
well,
Geez,
I thought it was just dinner.
Right?
So I guess,
right.
That's pretty good news.
I mean,
it seems like everything
else is on the table.
So then they end up back
in her place and she says,
oh,
sorry,
the,
you know,
we,
the rule changed a little bit.
Now it's like,
I know genital contact.
So they're making out.
And she says,
okay,
sorry,
you know,
my boyfriend says no genital contact,
right?
So he says,
okay,
that's fine.
So then she says,
wait a minute,
they're getting all hot and heavy.
She says,
wait a minute,
she goes to the other room,
she comes back and she's got these black
latex gloves on and she starts giving
him a hand job because like,
apparently with the gloves there's no
contact and then she gives him a Dildo.
So there's like,
all this crazy stuff is going on.
And he told me this story.
He's like,
this was so far beyond what
I would have anticipated.
Exactly.
And it got really freaky
because of these rules.
Of course,
it made me think about drugs,
you know,
like,
hey,
if coca leaf is illegal,
well then they're going to make cocaine.
You know,
if grasp,
if you can't just grow
grass in your backyard,
then you're going to get hydroponic,
you know,
super grass.
It's like you make these rules,
you know,
like hard liquor,
right?
Prohibition is what started
gin and all this kind of stuff,
right?
So you make rules to try to contain a
natural human appetite and what happens is
it gets explosive,
right?
Just like a bomb.
The bomb needs the
containment to be explosive,
otherwise it's just nothing.
It gets a natural human inclination that
I could see loud and clearly with my
kids.
When you try to keep
kids from doing things,
they automatically like,
why the fuck should I listen to you?
I want,
that's what I want to do.
They get angry.
It's like it's a natural human response
because all of our entire history of
humanity has been people
trying to dominate people,
people trying to control people.
So our natural thing is to resist.
It's why the biggest slut always
have like super religious parents.
There you go.
Jesus Christ.
Folks.
Is it that easy?
Does Dr Christopher Ryan
have to explain it that easy?
Yes.
Nina Hartley's.
Parents interestingly,
were communists who were
blacklisted in Berkeley.
Really?
Interesting.
Yeah,
she's an old hippy.
She's a,
she's a,
she's an odd case.
Yeah,
she like,
she's one of the rare ones where you,
you always connect human,
like girls who were into
porn or getting into that,
you always connected with
some sort of an abuse.
Yeah.
You know,
some human aberration,
but now with her she seems like just
a crazy old hippie freak doesn't seem
dirty.
It's fun.
Like,
yeah,
it's weird.
Yeah,
no,
she's,
she's an interesting person.
I enjoy.
What is the,
what is the weirdest thing you've gotten
out of this study of human sexuality
because it's,
your book is incredibly enlightening
and I think Dunkin's uh,
his,
uh,
definition of you as a shame exercise is
really a perfect one because it puts so
many things into perspective and it makes,
it makes so many weird patterns
of behavior that we follow.
It's sort of enlightens
you on the origins of them,
but what is like one of the weirdest
things that you've found in this pursuit?
Well yeah,
there are so many,
you know,
obviously these things pop
up in every conversation,
but I think one of the most,
uh,
memorable and,
and moving in a way was when I went
looking for the first documented case of a
key parties and,
you know,
partner swapping and
that sort of thing in,
in modern America,
not these sex in the 19th century,
20th century stuff.
I thought it would be,
um,
you know,
some commune in Berkeley with a bunch
of hippies and Hendrix posters and,
you know,
whatever waterbeds and,
that Kinda thing.
And uh,
but it wasn't,
it was World War Two fighter pilots in
the Pacific who had the highest fatality
rate of any branch of the
military in World War II.
Twenty five percent of them died in
action when they were back on base,
I guess in Hawaii or the west coast.
They had key parties where they and their
partners would come to these parties,
put the keys in,
you know,
like in the ice storm.
I don't know if you saw that movie,
great movie,
um,
and randomly sleep with each
other's wives or girlfriends.
Right?
And um,
you know,
these are all like super,
genetically.
Yeah,
good looking dudes.
All Alpha males obviously and the
women they were with were hot.
So I don't think anyone was worried about,
you know,
pulling the short straw to the,
the short key.
Um,
but,
you know,
I,
I thought,
well,
okay sure,
these guys are facing death.
They want to get it while they can.
Right.
But then in the interviews
I read with the survivors,
what they said was,
yeah,
okay,
we were young,
we were strong,
we were,
have,
you know,
we were getting laid but we
could have gotten laid anywhere.
You know,
we could have gone to
a bar and gotten lay.
We did because
we wanted those other guys.
We wanted our buddies to love
our women so that if I die,
I know these guys will take care of her
because they love her because they've
been with her.
They know her.
Right?
It's like it,
it moved me so much to read that because
a lot of the accounts from the Amazon
are the same.
These guys are facing a difficult life.
You can go hunting one
day and you get your,
the Hunty,
you know,
things can go wrong really fast,
so you want people to love each other,
not exclusively because then
they take care of each other,
they take care of each other's kids,
they share their food,
they,
you know,
they look out for each other.
And that's really the essence of humanity.
Have you explored the idea
that the opposite trend that
we are finding ourselves
in now where people are just gravitating
towards monogamy at least culturally,
at least on paper,
that this,
uh,
this move towards that ideal is because
we're safer is because we're more likely
to be protected.
We don't need these.
We in sort of a natural inclination
to move towards a deeper bond with one
individual person.
I don't know that I'd call
it a natural inclination,
but you know,
I,
I tend to see it more as a byproduct
of institutional and economic forces.
I see that as also being natural.
And I know it sounds very contradictory
when I look at Wolf behavior.
Yeah,
I,
I don't take our crazy fucked up weird
behavior and not think that it's natural.
Even though there's consciousness
involve and choices involved,
there's something about the
pattern of human behavior.
When I look at it as a whole,
where I see it's kind of arrogant
to assume that this isn't natural.
It seems that almost
everything is natural.
That's the thing.
It depends how you define.
I mean you could,
if you take a real
global perspective,
you could say as I tend to think of it
that we are not where the ants and the
ant hill and the ant hill is what's
evolving and that's the sort of the,
the,
the location of the selection.
In other words,
as individuals,
we think we're what's evolving,
but I think what's evolving
is society's corporations,
these institutions that,
that include us and they don't
give a shit if we're happy or not.
This,
this larger being that we're in or a
part of as we fuel them with electricity,
with commerce,
with whatever.
They literally act like a life form.
This is the same way as technology.
Like Marshall Mcluhan said,
we are the sexual organs.
Those machines,
well,
as we fuel the,
the,
the desire for new laptops,
we keep that alive.
Right.
And,
and you know,
uh,
when Mitt Romney said corporations
are people in my friend,
I don't think he was
thinking in these terms,
but they're not people,
but they're living beings,
they have a stake and staying alive.
They have a vested interest
and if step on us to do it,
they'll do it,
you know,
fucking crazy is that.
And they can get to do it for them.
Frankenstein,
you know,
that was the whole Frankenstein
myth and it's happier,
you know,
don't fear it.
Don't you know how in 2001 it's here,
it's,
it's been happening for quite awhile.
Monsanto doesn't give a shit if
they produce food that kills us.
No,
as long as they've cornered the market,
well they also produce
DDT and Agent Orange.
Sure.
So itself,
they've been making fucked
up choices for a long time.
You know what I told that story
about the pilots in San Diego.
I was given a talk down there and this
guy came up to me after and he said,
I'm a,
I'm A.
I was a fighter pilot in Vietnam.
Same thing.
Different war,
same thing.
Wow.
So it's a natural behavior pattern.
Apparently it's a culture
among fighter pilots that a,
they.
Well that they're facing death.
Right.
And,
and I found it.
I'd done a lot of research and hospitals
and I found a very amplified sexuality
in hospitals center because
they're facing as well.
Cops.
Yeah,
sure.
Anybody who's on the edge and Hulk Hogan,
Hulk Hogan Swim.
That MMA fighter.
No,
he's not.
He's just interviewed at the airport
and just said something silly.
Everybody blew that out of proportion.
Yeah.
Hulk Hogan,
they used to.
He was a web swapper.
The AG guys,
much of the.
Was it the New York jets
and the giants had Ryan.
There was this.
Did you hear about this?
No,
this controversy because there were,
there were pictures on
the Internet of him,
his wife and another dude,
and the wife was like either naked or in
lingerie and the other dude was sucking
her toes.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
That's where I checked out
the glove.
Weird about that,
man.
We're real weird about that.
It's interesting.
It's a,
it's,
it's fascinating to just see
the trends and how they've,
how they've changed with the environment.
Yeah,
and how different they are as you were
saying in cultures like there was a at
the same time that thing was happening
in the states and it was a huge to do.
There was a soccer coach in England
who got nabbed coming out of a massage
parlor with happy endings and all that
and the press was there and snapping all
these pictures and they said,
do you know their tie?
How hookers in there?
He said,
of course I know die yolkers in this,
why?
I go there.
And it was like,
what,
how dare you not be ashamed,
you know?
And then they went and interviewed
his wife and his wife said,
Oh God,
if I could get him to go to
Thai hookers twice a week,
I'd pay for it.
It relaxes him.
He's better at his job.
You know,
how is this any of your business?
Just completely trumped the,
the,
you know,
the assumption that she'd be
ashamed and run away from it.
Like,
Hey,
this is none of your damn business.
Sounds like you've got a good wife.
Nailed it.
Imagine if the Clintons had done that.
Maybe they did in,
you
know,
maybe you think they did.
Maybe Hillary was just mad that
he wasn't bringing checks home.
I mean,
who knows,
who fucking cares either those businesses.
Oh,
it's just so weird how the desire for
sex and our appetite for sex is not
represented in any way.
I mean it's represented a bit in the
media and film and advertising and stuff
like that,
but it's not.
Honestly,
it's not honestly engaged.
It's not honestly described.
It's funny though because like I
saw this Carter or in a cartoon,
a commercial a couple of weeks ago for
some plunger or some plumbing thing to
clear your drains and it,
the,
the idea was,
and it was,
you know,
the whatever the major brand plumbing
thing is and this stuff has the chemical
nastiness,
but it also has like a plastic thing you
can stick down to pull the hair thing.
And so it was like double action.
Right?
And so the ad was,
this woman answers the door and
it's this really good looking dude,
and the dude's like,
yeah,
I'm here to snake your drain baby.
And she says,
oh.
And she's like,
all flustered in,
Oh yes,
come with me.
And then someone else
knocks and she opened it.
It's another dude.
And he's like,
yeah,
I'm here to help.
Oh,
oh,
two of you.
Oh,
what?
What country?
That's here in the states.
And I,
I linked to it.
I,
I tweeted,
I said,
has this actually been on TV?
Because someone sent
me the link on Youtube.
I said,
has anyone seen this on TV?
And a bunch of people.
Rebecca.
Oh yeah.
I've seen it on TV.
It's on
like,
wow.
Wow.
What's up with that?
Well,
congratulations,
whoever company put that out.
Graduations for sneaking that through.
Can we?
Can we end on that?
Can we pull that out?
It's quite good.
It's,
it's,
I think it's plunger,
dual action plunger or whatever that
somebody can find that to tool action
plunger.
That's hilarious.
The woman's like in the grocery store
and she sees these two guys and has this
whole fantasy.
What's going on with that TV show that?
Well,
it's great,
man.
Last time I was here I guess
we talked probably off the air,
but.
But I'm like a whole shitload of
production companies want to do it.
Everybody thinks it's going to go.
Is this it?
Yeah.
Impact.
Total impacts are.
So here's snake.
He's hot.
He's hot too.
I'm here to flush your pipe.
Wow.
She's letting her hair down and everything
while he's going to go upstairs and
there's just nothing but shit.
She takes these massive logging or poop.
He's fucking wood chips.
It's just not blood.
The very.
And She just woke up.
That's her.
That's her fantasy.
Yeah.
The under sex housewife shits reality
and the gay guy holding the fruit.
The Gay guy working with the melons.
The two of them are just gonna.
Use her as an excuse to get together.
That's how they're doing.
That's what double
penetration is when two guys,
when they're both in the
vagina at the same time,
they're just using the
woman as a container.
So they could rub dicks.
Com.
Scrotum,
buddies.
Yeah,
that's what they're doing.
Listen,
a fascinating.
Again,
three hours just flew right by.
Matt.
We could do this every time.
We still talked about like one
paragraph and your book will come.
We'll cover it.
One page,
but it's a brilliant book.
And folks,
if you haven't read it,
it's called sex at dawn.
You can get it on Amazon,
which is a sponsor of the show.
Um,
it's available as an audio book.
It's also available of course in,
in book form and it's fucking great.
And you were working on another book too.
Civilized today.
Is that,
is that coming out soon?
It's due October first.
Should come out next spring
unless I don't get to it.
All right.
I'm going to start real soon.
Sex at dawn.
It's available now.
And your podcast,
how do people get it?
Tangentially speaking.
You can get it@aferalaudio.com
or you can get it on itunes.
It's on itunes.
Beautiful.
And it's Chris Ryan,
phd on twitter and thanks brother.
Really appreciate it.
Always good times.
All right.
Thank you everybody for tuning in.
Thanks.
Everybody.
Came out to Nashville this weekend.
We had a great fucking time.
Nashville was awesome.
I was exactly what I needed.
Wanted to go to a small club in a workout,
some new material.
And Man,
there's nothing like
working at a comedy club.
I've been doing a lot of theaters lately.
I forgot how much fun
it is to do a weekend,
like a 300 seater.
Nashville is awesome.
What a fucking great town.
Thank you everybody who
came out because uh,
I had the time of my life.
It was,
it was beautiful and Tommy
bonds was with me as well.
Thompson girl.
We had a great time.
It was seriously some of the best
sets I've ever had in my life.
People were amazing.
Thanks to squarespace for sponsoring
this episode of the podcast.
If you go to squarespace.com
forward slash joe,
or you could sign up.
You don't even have to
use your credit card,
but if you decided to sign up,
use the code named Joe and the number
three and you will save yourself some
Moolah.
You sexy bitches and you're like,
no way Joe.
And I'm like,
yeah,
way save some money and it's
an awesome fucking website.
We're also brought to you by on it.com.
That's o n n I t use the codename Rogan
and you could save yourself 10 percent
of any and all supplements.
Go to a Rogan dot tin top con.
That is our last and final sponsor
that's painting is the cell phone company
that doesn't have contracts and rolls
over your minutes and they're just
basically bad ass Rogan.ting.com will
save you 25 bucks off either service or a
phone.
Uh,
we will be back tomorrow
with the Great Bill Burger,
one of my favorite human beings.
Some of the funniest comics working today.
And uh,
so we'll see you then.
You fucks,
we love the shit out of
you and we'll see you soon.
Big Kiss.
Yeah.